all right we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast and the Lords of
gaming dotnet episode number 102 and
it's a glorious another glorious Sunday
back at the roundtable on the Lord's Day
I'm very excited about our special
guests and we've got Google leaks ps4
and iOS devices EA skip in III lob OVR
Seconal and days gone and the xbox sad
to discuss so we're gonna get right into
it I want to introduce some Lords of
podcasting who are not only good friends
to the room but who truly provide a
distinct insight on gaming news cinema
and those powerful beings we respect
from every comic book universe
introducing one half of the multiverse
show panel which includes one of the
most sarcastic podcasts hosting the game
the Lord of Chaos and the owner of East
at the Bethesda Kingdom combined with
the gaming Gambino and Dawn of deletion
and finished off by the chief
achievements an infinite reoccurring
guest of the multiverse from MC Philly
and Canada and for the first time making
their debut into the realm of the Lord's
together
my main Lord anchorman v2 might be the
truth and undead 3xv i multiverse show
how ru Lord's doing God biggest hater
for anchorman doing good doing good try
to be on the show again
and not just as a random guest
appearance listen you've got the most
appearances on pops in like he's the
villain in the game
every week for the past couple weeks
yeah first out with it guys go no sir
I'm doing pretty good so far oh I see
that fall our car break up a bit we got
Mike Peter drove his debut out here
let's go what's going on everybody
I have long awaited the day where I
would infiltrate the Lord
the Lords of iron to delete whoever and
classify them as obsolete long overdue
for a minute you know yeah man I'm
excited to be here glad you guys had me
on no doubt man and of course the king
of achievements himself the new Rainbow
six siege operator what's going on like
this I'm just here I'm chillin and I
guess I'm supposed to be filling in for
creepy by so I guess I gotta be Italian
Ivan promised me pizza and beer and I
don't see any front never that Lord in
the building man good to have you back
they can see the multi first represent
at least half of the multi-verse
represent it's good man so you know we
already have the Lords of gaming of Four
Horsemen the original Lords of the room
my co-host with the co most my brother
from another mother the difficult game
Conqueror and the half of the young wolf
Mahmud Lord addict how you doing sir
oh you gotta see my man epic beard
[Laughter]
than a on PC now so grinding on that and
finally hit 500 that's what's up there
you go bill tell me what else you've
been playing with does it he's just
saving it for my segment that's all are
you just not talking right now
oh yeah like you guys hear me to audio
cut out on my own for a little bit I
just decide destiny that's all that's
all no doubt no doubt and of course you
know we have our most technical gaming
and of course we have our most technical
gaming Lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single player selfish experience and
also the sastra darkness mister offline
profile Illuminati and lore patron of
the iron brake mom-in-law sovereign how
you doing sir hello sir
you should be called cloud messaging
I'm confused that's taller orchids
smooth because they're now the kids move
really have a bone to pick with me cuz
Yahweh to the the week I'm not here to
go ham ham on the red dead slant
unchecked red dead slander last week not
feeling that it was not about that I
already knew I already knew Kings love
for it was full gazing I knew that
I knew I knew once he got past the
graphics going at me you even allow me
to say give you my rebuttal for what I
did this week in it you know okay so if
you out here jumping out the window see
okay so for wait wait to you with you to
go you can rebut and then I'll take it
back if I have an episode when are the
batteries to that dot putting that quite
a bit man they're gonna die will you
keep all wishing yes I was not feeling a
slender all right you know for guys I
love you guys but you're in the bushes
don't come back you I think you were
cool people you're just wanting people
that don't like right good enough I love
you bro but you going don't come back to
the realm the man this is coming from
the man that play Kingdom Hearts twice
you did that to yourself twice what you
do so you don't play games oh oh when
did I say you don't play games
I said you like whack games when did I
say you play you to play games so you go
sit here act like every game I play is
whack no just that one just the one that
I pointed back with bullets he but
that's what have you been playing saw
what's going on bit Duke will make me a
super Sam on his ass mmm-hmm language
and let's go guys now what you been
playing me Hobbes in the bushes what is
what Department
probably dead him addict EMP here we go
again me okay yeah it was the Attic EMP
that's what it was um now I just play
some DMC five that was it a little bit
that's all I got to play oh is that a
topic talking to everyone segment by the
way we have we have some patreon stuff
at the end of everything we forget about
you guys and of course we had the
Incredible Hulk of this aka
the excess gamer ooh the lord of combat
sports was a man of his convictions
demands nothing less than that premium
experience and is the leader of the
fraud alert oh man ooh
beloved Lord King how you doing sir I'm
doing so great I'm doing so great I
gotta have on shades today cuz these
eyes as big as golf balls all puffy as
hell it's not going down you're not
gonna be shaming me today I had the
weirdest wall ready shirt you see that
the generals in charge definitely to
keep adding your man fallout 76 in
control Oh last night it was an epic
night we had a drinks food and being
merry hanging out with loads of drones
of their own shout out to runaway dragon
TV aka the meatiest shout out to Tim
dogs shout out to the giant Megatron
whoa it was a no particular order you
know it was an epic night we were at a
nice restaurant trying t-bone steaks
that I can't eat but hey it was
definitely a great night it was a great
night all the way around what about my
team this week um
destiny oh the drifter stuff apex
Oh shout-out to l-boogie for throwing me
in the bushes with all you anthem plays
playing I told you guys that I would not
fight again I will play the game with
somebody gifted to me waited until I was
in the party she said yeah watch this so
I'm playing I'm thinking this is the
message on my xbox right and I'm
thinking as division saying is ready to
download ready to download click the
button listen you got a gift from
l-boogie shoutout l you talked a lot you
talked to our Bible from the jump so you
can't sit there say I had a hidden price
tag and I was like no one can do it and
I was playing at all this week every
time that they were on I was playing
with monkey I was playing with Chris and
the first my first experience with it I
was so low like I'm out there I'm like I
hate this game so bad tell you something
but she just playing it because
somebody's like they forced you to like
really like busy when he forced me to
play our do me a favor I need you to
want that fright this is how fraud works
addy if I've said all this garbage trash
and y'all saw me online
so I'm not gonna front
oh I'm not gonna front oh oh
the feeling of of superiority enemies
when you're with your friends and you're
comboing and you're doing super thing
you're shooting menu moving I'm out
there level to these dudes is level 30
I'm playing on Grand Master and not
dying hmm all right I'm out there taking
people up did I little did I know that
the game was broken to the extent that I
can have this gun later this week I
found out that the game is severely
broken to the point that you get a level
one gun that can actually be there do
you know stand the test of time but
we'll have the fraud before us bill must
also say then I stayed sheet of my work
no somebody would have got the game and
I still four frames from playing the
game and I still would have said now I'm
not gonna do it yo then that's being a
fraud it's been a lot of anthem for you
it's been a lot of it right now I'm
level 15 I don't have any master work
anything I'm still learning the tower
I'm still learning how the structure of
the game goes but I can see that where
they put a lot of their self into the
game oh you know I would tell people
don't skip past the story and I y'all
complaining that destiny doesn't have
story they actually give you dialogue
trees for characters they actually
giving you story law around the world so
if you're gonna play anthem and you want
one of those destiny people that is not
a new story then don't skip any of the
damn story and get all the story because
I don't want to hear Oh Adam has no
story cuz that about
footed yeah why you conflicted you can
sleep what happened now you gonna jump
ship no if somebody told me yo sure I go
by this game I would say hell to the no
I would say don't put your money do not
invest a nickel in this game I also told
you somebody gifted it to me now
what I have taken my money and brought
this game hell to the no but you know
where El Bulli is having fun with me
right now having to explain myself in
front of the old man she's I told her
she had to get on the show but I don't
see her yet I'm not in the bushes well
you know what you're playing what was
that Kingdom Hearts so I guess you're in
the bushes that's the new thing when I
breathe some of you guys got a hit in
your desk you gotta take you out here
fraud which Kingdom are you
it's me Lord Cognito I'm here they're
real this is the realm of the ILP that's
all you want to hit what you need to
hear
same with King season of The Drifter a
little bit of our star link for the
switch and prepping for that division
launch on Tuesday I'm excited man a lot
of stuff going on so a lot to talk about
a lot of show and we got into what the
Lords have been planned so I want to
start with Lords of the multi-verse
their video game system history now mind
you both lord anchorman and Lord undead
have received the royal treatment before
please checkout aisle P number one a
current that's when you was on I don't
think number one actually were I allowed
back then we had an intervention series
Eggman has eight or nine I got more
seniority than you do at it he was I was
pretty one
okay little nonsense and go somewhere
else okay anyway so that was here and
then obviously undead we had him
I'll p71 for some great and hilarious
history but we want to talk about that
mic PT truth and as well the formation
of one of the most unique podcasts out
there the multi-verse so let's start
with Mike Pete the truth your video game
system history what got you into gaming
and let's just talk about it man so I
mean I've been gaming since I was like
three four years old um first system I
ever had was a mattel intellivision if
you could believe that rule so this is
going way back where the controller had
a little dial pad on it with like little
phone number clicker pad on it go it was
crazy so I've had basically every system
in it list since then you know Nintendo
Super Nintendo Genesis the only system I
haven't owned regrettably is a Saturn
I've always wanted to own one since
don't worry mister um hey I'm glad you
brought that up since we talked about
gaming history my opinion is the
Dreamcast the greatest console whole
time like hands down hands down at all
time but um but you know real you waited
let's just call it what it was the SATs
a didn't appeal to you for whatever
reason but you know it you know it
didn't deplore me Batman
and but go what am i one of my favorite
fighting games of all time is primal
rage and the best home version of primal
rage is on the Saturn
I've been trying to I've been trying to
find one so I could play that but a lot
of this a lot of the game shops prime
you don't have them but but that's
basically it man like I said I've been
gaming since kits though game into this
day you know ps4 Xbox switch so now let
me ask you this because I know you as a
person really likes like the like
wrestling and I'm follows for a wrestle
stuff that now did you have a 64 did you
get into any of those wrestling games or
even on Playstation or even further on
so best wrestling game I would say that
I've ever played was on the ps2 here
comes the pain mmm okay okay here comes
the pain was great here comes
and also on the n64 Wrestlemania they
was Wrestlemania 2000 on the n64 was a
good one isn't that the one we used to
call with the black Mouth for the
opening yes yeah that was another game
that was a hockey game his boobs which
he said those was classics he said here
comes the pain was fired here comes the
pain was fire really was so wait Mike
you never got a chance to play D in 64
games that no mercy the night you never
rec remaining was that but was that but
it was the the next with the beta
version gay right I never played the
original one though but I did play the
Wrestlemania mm that was good I was
really good yeah because he was yeah was
that the one you create your own
pay-per-view and all that - well that
was Lee I'm pretty sure I was in there
yeah ass was no doubt something you just
transition to the 360 and you know you
know honestly that's another I never
owned a 360 360 that gen I was ps3 in
the way that gen I didn't only 360 that
judge Wow we need to throw this man in
the bushes that he owned a ps3 a long
time ago they brought you on so that we
could you know ambush you what happened
with no 360 I had pee I had ps2 fro I
had ps2 for a while like I stuck with
that for a while that gen and then it
was like mm mm eight nine ish I got the
way and then 2010 I got my ps3 so I kind
of I kind of missed the early part of
that Jenny I didn't get started with
that gentle closer towards the middle
okay well convinced it odd it gained
some ground yeah okay no doubt no doubt
I saw something that's of good history
right there
now on Lord anchorman I'm no way I
talked about you at home I LP number one
and I just need to know can we ever
undead I gotta get I gotta get some
confirmation on stories so let's talk to
you Lorna ik as far as the formation of
the moat I first had this stock and I
also want to shout out the remaining
members off fame entertainment Sam
Tolbert you know saying uh James Wilson
so let's talk about how did this whole
didn't come together so so originally
whenever I started multiverse podcast it
was a pre-recorded show between me and
Cal from chick pot cast shadow before I
was before I was a part of tick or
anything like that
we won see we did pre-recorded shows
they didn't like me before episodes and
we're like this is stupid
I'm tired pre recording this the netting
this is just a me ask mmm and so we
stopped doing the show and then I
brought it back but I brought a bag of
fame and we did fame entertain Minh and
I started the show back and we kind of
did more like as a guest show okay so we
had we grabbed some random people or we
grabbed industry types we losers had
random people on and so sometimes you
have no idea if it was gonna be like oh
yeah this is some dude I just met
randomly in a party or oh yeah there's a
low-key developer you have no clue that
was the idea and it was always just
random so over time we we did that for a
bit and I got I got no bunch of gaming
groups
that's where I met undead and we were in
a group called we game here yep yeah
during that time I was on my fallout 4
reign of terror was the fallout 4 promo
train in full swing at that time oh man
people were legit pissed people try to
get banned from the group for posting
height for Fallout 4 it was really funny
but um so Nick Nick and I met each other
through that I got him on the show at
that point um it wasn't too long it was
a Nick it was like maybe like episode 15
or 20 or something like that yeah that
was back when you guys used to do
seasons I came in on season 2 I believe
yeah the way we originally did it was we
figured it more like a Netflix season
because
doing a show every single week people
get tired of that they just come up yeah
so what we would do was we would say
okay this is season one and we would do
one Episode a week every single week
probably do that for like over 13 weeks
that take a break for a month right and
we did that for bid so season two we
brought an icon and it stuck and he has
really worked for us so we're very cool
so we kept them on boat so Nick story is
true and their story is true with the
reoccurring the infinite reoccurring
cast that's I became part of the pocket
yeah and then after that we joined chick
partly joined a tech network mm-hmm and
we did our projects there and worked
through that and it was great and so
during that time that's what we met
James and James was one of our writers
and he was doing a another show called
tick United and it was like him and
somebody else and they were just talking
movies mm-hmm it's a really well that's
fine we'll just we'll figure this out
and so we we asked him hey you want to
come on because dick United wasn't
really working out wasn't grabbing a
bass and we just we got him on board and
we kind of a on the podcast of the
movies so we did that for a little bit
and over time like we really kind of
develop our podcast was about like just
having a good time talk about whatever
nice and over time I want to say was a
2016 Mike where you and I met
yeah I was 2016 okay about 2016 and was
Martin Luther King Day holla
yes right story on Twitter and I see an
individual called J tech TV not gonna
get too much in here s plays a very hard
yeah he goes Harper PlayStation and I
just happened to see something I think
was a J main from a press star pod oh
it's not the PSP yes sir
and I just happen to see this
conversation and I'm like cool let's
let's see what's going on and I see Mike
had asked Jay tech about
like his PlayStation Legion mm-hmm
picture yes and hey can I get one of
those and he then he asked you like did
so you play with like he wanted to know
what I played on at the time and I said
to him I have a ps4 and I got a Wii U I
how do we you at the time and he says
something like nah man this is only for
PlayStation gamers no dick riders laughs
whoa and so I see that and so we just
start roasting where did we just start
going at him and um what was it I posted
that I'm I think my I only tweeted one
thing in JTAG I got blocked so quick
today we can judge a man not for the
console which he owns but the content of
like a vlog or something does that sound
like I can I met as we start talking for
a bit like we got him on maybe a month
or two after that yeah so again expanded
and then out like I said so pretty much
literally the foundation of it was all
it was just was always from the
beginning was gonna be gaming and comics
and you know cinema was that always the
initial like goal for multiverse when we
started initially so like when during
the CAO era it was more of a comics
movie stuff focus group or ever show but
then whenever during the fame era you
know we you were mostly gaming at that
time and when we would talk about like
okay what superhero movie came out we
could talk about that usually were both
in that and I was something that I think
most people would get into as well when
we brought James on we became more of a
cinema podcast and having that extra
focus so it gives a little more
flexibility and as you guys are quite
aware sometimes people who now
yes yeah yeah so yeah we've kind of
always been like a catch-all podcast
mm-hmm it's kind of hitting up whatever
we need to be know though though and
Lord undead also aka the lord of
perspective joining that group manning
it you know saying so what you just
figured you stick around huh I just I
show up when I can I'm not as frequent
lately because my wife's doing some
online schooling to become a nurse so
I'm a lot more inconsistent than I used
to be but I still make it out when I can
and I always enjoyed myself and like I
said there's nobody that I've met in the
Twitter space that I would have met
without being on multiverse and getting
to know everybody and everything else
because I'd even have Twitter iPhones
like off you're gonna be on podcast you
gotta be on Twitter I'm like okay I'll
do that
terrible fan fest you need to have
Twitter because that's how they talk I'm
reading the evil influence of Twitter to
everyone's that's what's up good little
history and you know so what about last
question egg what give me the order of
multiverse remember as far as when they
came who is like the the last person to
come on Sam
also that's a bit good little history
going on so you know we gotta ask the
Lord here of the multiverse the top five
question so we go saw what might be the
truth
Mike I mean those top five video games
of franchises of all time sir so games
are whole franchises either or either
whatever is our most important to you
alright so if you're asking my top five
games of all time I gotta go number five
Gran Turismo 3 on the ps2 number four I
probably got to go
res evil threes number for an evil 3
it's evil 3 that that's still like the
remake for as Evil 2 was up there that's
number 2 versus Napster me yep great um
that was for if I gotta go number three
I'm going Final Fantasy 10 mm um
number 2 what you got I'm probably gonna
say number 2 I'm gonna go well number
one is Shenmue number number one is
definitely fed mo number one is Shenmue
number two more to go Metal Gear Solid 3
oh my - hol up hol up hol up did I just
list a stealth game in his top 5 those
are the air everybody knows I don't like
stealth games especially games where
they force you into doing stealth but
the original and Metal Gear Solid
trilogy like Marcel 2 3 and also Twin
Snakes those games I loved I loved those
games those those the only stealth games
I got honestly say I ever really enjoyed
I got actually about 2/10 that is unique
like a shout to the chat everyone think
that so 7 didn't impact you the way 10
did I thought it was I thought it was
good but I thought 10 as far as the
storyline the characters the world the
summons it just like it just had a
bigger effect on me also also 10 was the
first one that had voice acting in it
too so it made it a little bit more
impactful that's what's up man what you
say attic about it is one of my final
favorite final fantasies - mm and I'm
also one of the people - I think 10 -
gets a bad rap I liked it no I'm not
about that life
so you can know what don't you like
about that the combat was fun the
storyline was a good continuation for
final phase he tagged what I understand
what everybody doesn't like about it I
just I don't like the way they want the
direction they brought some chick named
paint on there that they you know they
explain who she was but you had to play
like half the game to figure it out they
completely got rid of the Sphere Grid
that made 10 special I'm not about
I got like probably two days in that
game I'm just not about it
that's what's up now last last question
Mike you got one of my favorite near and
dear franchises she's number one which
is Shane Moore I'd be I need you to
explain to the people why that was on
your number one you know what that game
did for the time was nothing short of
revolutionary at the time I mean that
the fact that you could go through Rio's
house and you could open drawers and
take out of the drawers like no other
game was immersing you in the works at
that time it was just crazy
it was crazy no other games like that we
had a day/night cycle yeah get a job you
go to get job you got to go home and go
to bed you could buy stuff at the
vending machines Beck's arcade perfect
games that you can play in an arcade
there was nets but he had what was the
decaying I had on hang on mm-hmm Space
Harrier II Space Harrier and hang on
fully every lady man ass was so shot the
Boeing says Sheva was first real gig
yeah it felt like a real gig like it was
a good life simulator like it was just
great before it's a bad good Liz Mike so
well I got it got undead back so uh
undead I need to know do we have any
revisions to your list last time you own
on our piece everyone you get hit man
Metal Gear Solid Splinter Cell Halo and
God of War does that need revising all
that needs revising because for the
simple reason is back then I was still
running our laptop so I picked up a PC
again more recently got a nice little
desktop and I started diving back into
some some of those great 90s PC games
game
ya know baldur's gate - and all eight
discs of it are bad who comes off the
list in if it's boulders gate
Oh for baldur's gate list as metal goose
or the cell a low burner cell goes off
the list for boulders game bushes imma
tell people right now if you want the
pure 90s FPS genre if I want to give you
an encapsulation of the best part of pc
FPS gaming in the 90s go on Steam right
now and for I think four dollars you can
pick up a game called redneck rampage I
remember that go pick that up
it comes in MP so neck so Nick Verizon's
your odo it's not in your top five okay
listen here Mike we gonna throw down sir
sir I gotta ask you because you brought
this up and you almost put on your game
year year list how does it feel when you
boot up NBA Live and boot up the
multiplayer and all you have to play
against his kids smooth because every
time a multiverse we do a game of the
year show game of the generation show
horizon zero dawn comes up and that
comes to Nick vote because well you know
I don't really like it but I'm just
gonna vote it ahead all these other game
setting but look I I have explained my
horizon zero dawn defense endlessly it's
one of those things I don't like the
game I don't think it's that great but
when nine out of ten people disagree
with me then I'm wrong and I like if I
like I can sit there and like it's like
it's like everyone trashing the Attic
for Kingdom Hearts Kingdom Hearts is
amazing franchise put some respect on
its name but listen all I gotta say is
that horizon zero dawn if when the
sequel is done if they have better melee
about facial animations that don't look
like Mass Effect Andromeda and give me
voice acting that's actually worth while
I'm there day one oh that's crazy
and Lord anger me I went back and dug in
the crates man and we had you on at the
time it was I not on YouTube but if you
want those old archives go to our
SoundCloud go to our logo I we were the
iron Lords intervention we were trying
to convince anchorman to play destiny at
that time that he gave us is history we
only had we weren't doing top 5 and he
only had a two games on his list which
was a fallout new vegas and bioshock so
lord ain't a man i need your top 5 OG
list maybe a pole at 76 i love you guy
copper ii EMP was that coming through
buddy games everybody know alright so
back at the time of ili number one you
had fallout new vegas and you had
bioshock but we weren't doing a top five
back then so you need more franchise or
i need to know if those two changed as
well okay so top 5 let's see alright
mmm no I don't like 5th is got looks
like a tie between two different games
franchise minecraft and dark fighters
minecraft ok yeah as there everyone
multiverse can obtain I went hard on
minecraft that's actually one of the
games that I first started playing with
anchorman was mine credit that's what's
up well actually I can tame the amount
of people that anchorman convinced to
buy an xbox and then play Minecraft with
us was the divine world that that was
like massive that me an acre man and
like for other people though it was huge
I was hosting game night on Tuesday a
and they were like oh I see you play
Minecraft and like definitely because I
remember you have me that was that one
month I went super hard for achievements
yo-yo get in this minecraft right quick
I got you a couple with remember that
month I was training to go fight again I
was going up against you gave me a good
list I was like yeah baby I'm in the gym
let's get these achieve with for free
let's go like 30 minutes I have to keep
pressure on Dave man he was coming
strong at the hip yeah minecraft see
minecraft the dark stars kind of tied at
fifth dart I love Darksiders that that
game any of our games I nor exciters 3 I
just beat that recently I'm like Dave I
want to get today I'm gonna get support
not know dark spiders 3 is that great
rebound game like after you finish like
a really long ass game like you thinner
foot you're 3 you finish whatever game
even playing hundreds of hours with you
just boot that up chill you can listen
to the story if you want don't have to
just good game good game play all the
way through No
so dark minecraft been at it we're still
keeping full on like yeah well guy I
gotta keep falling to Vegas number 4
Sasson screed whole franchise ah only
good one bad assassin's creed as a unit
here I see what they were trying to do
with unity the fastest really when that
thing came out on the Xbox one it was
okay it wasn't that but the problem was
when they started making patches to it
because I hate with the Xbox one
everyone has a better CPU than the ps4
and so it could process having more
people on screen yeah but ever since
they started patching it for whatever
reason started running like [ __ ]
three strikes already already we've
breaking limitless alright three
spider-man all the time when I buy the
ps4 what I'm talking about
all the spider-man games no but actually
nine yeah whenever killing that came out
on PlayStation 1 right I played that
like every Sunday every Sunday play all
the way through to completion
it was so of that game that's a and -
that was dope the oven
I got fallout that's gonna stay followed
your Vegas meeting to stand out
absolutely love that oh oh a dick fell
out a new podcast oh yeah we gotta watch
it yes we gotta watch what a fall out
yeah yeah yeah they're my favorites
still Bioshock so nevermind I got
background noise y'all y'all got excuse
me this is crazy
but anyway so anyway we got that out the
way as far as the top 5 revised so uh
Lord solved you want to take care of
some business sir yes sir get into this
patreon stuff ooh
take care of our patreon subscribers
that we appreciate help us out every
student 2000 subscriber you will get
nothing that's behind me yeah we've had
some inquiries about adding some some
tears that involve Lord Kings collection
anything from Lord Keynes collection I
would steer you in the direction of
sideshow calm on XM calm or how about
take yourself to ebay.com
unsubstantial here they'll get nothing
free from him we got my let's take care
business my Invicta
alright let's go with let's go oh so
first off Lord Xavier Medina thank you
so much for your support my brother
shout out the album followed by Lord
Korey lied dick Lord whiskey him so no
whiskey Lord
eight-balls
get yourself to e3 I need my chef let's
go yeah followed by the PlayStation brah
followed by Lord QX seven masters aka
Kareem H Oh reverse that cremates aka to
accept math people government out there
salute not know it's in debate you are
listing they government out Jesus Lord
slow-mo back slap thank you sir you
shall be O Lord fastback 67 68 thank you
now leaving at that thank you Lord
stitch 66 69 oh shout the stage that's
what's up and could support it around
knowing Lord John love that with the arm
be name I love that I love you outdoors
Lord sincere quintana sorry belly that's
my feet too and our brethren Lord gaming
Forte all shout out to Forte the
building in the building
oh wait I see him and the Lord of back
compat and x cloud Lord bills still well
great know all about their name right
there bottle my lord twos yes Lord
pudding only I like to lose money and of
course the original patreon subscriber
himself monkey punch you know we first
to chat is up first to shoot you in the
head and pub do you read my lord
Sammy Prescott oh god what's going on
and of course brethren once again
J Fonz Oh Captain Marvel [ __ ] I'm not
about that I don't know why what it does
is my read it would read my my webcam
it's like no using that yeah all the mic
was horrible asked what I noticed that
yeah I could not thank you that's why I
don't I don't know which ones playing
into some boosters yeah I did you
whatever this one is this is the better
one that's because it's it's the actual
one that's designed to speak into
interrupts a crisp rise your buttons at
the crispy oh you have the king of the
street teen lords now though himself the
cradle to the brain degrade a brave
cream Lord loaded pixels of course Lord
cat daddy fast Neji when that dream that
so we we got to update the people on
attic what is that going down hold up he
sent me some dates because I want to
make sure they he's available for a Amy
about a couple of seconds yeah he sent
me he said he will be free
anytime next Tuesday or Friday all right
so we're gonna put it out there once we
lock the date down the dream daddy
challenge is up attic will be doing it
probably be Tuesday because I'm off to
you to give me to be in a chat with you
could be in the chat man you to tell me
you you could be in the chat you had to
play the game
are you yes more the ps4 is up and
running now converting the division on I
don't even know I don't even know what
an Xbox looks like anyway no I'm joking
I still it's like I was telling a little
Cognito of it like I tried playing Devil
May Cry I had to literally put that on
the big screen to play it like what
comes to games like that I think I'm
gonna stick with I know it is because
she was playing on an inferior system
you got a PC that's equal to the X oh
yeah ok all right all right
the fuse plane I'm actually doing it
last but certainly not least our brother
from across the pond Lord's death singer
Oh s what's up baby thank you guys for
your continued support it is always much
appreciated so let's get into these
giveaways so let's start yeah you know
how that goes if your payments and not
come in if your payments to move no
you're out of the running
all right so let's start with this $10
gift card giveaway in the winner of the
$10 gift card is Jay Fonzarelli raking
it in with us dude
and I go rewatch captain $10 back so you
can in stadium watch the end credits
and we rigged already the rigs are
coming through Gregg's are coming in
Friday I know it's all coming in I
happen not to be looking at the screen
right now so you know I don't see all of
this slander or libel should it because
it's in print so the winner of our $20
gift card is Lord Kris Williams oh sorry
you know what it was what I put it in
the in the random name didn't write up
with the X those Pinkertons there all
right last but not least the winner of
our teespring giveaway yeah who's gonna
get the swag this one right one of our
teespring giveaway is gonna teach break
Oh get that T spring Lord bill still
well put that up I think he won last
more to Davey yeah this is it he's only
won twice in the entire time that he's
been he's been with us from the jump
yeah you know we don't win that's crazy
that's what's up your tune because that
back up at for once again thank you guys
for the support on patreon it's greatly
appreciated
I will hit you guys up in redeem to make
sure you get your codes I was gonna say
fast Mike said he says go say was rigged
but till fawns one so it's all good well
nobody hates on farms and farce is one a
lot my brother rise & grind in the
Chivers see that wait a long time and I
saw a man fresh out yeah he fresh out
see you in the realm cup he just got
through pulling a dime yo for that we're
good with the iron bank sir that is good
sir
all right let's get on with it man last
week's poll results are in and the
people have spoken to the question with
the rumors of a possible upcoming
Borderlands to be revealed by gearbox
which shooter do you think carries the
mantle of the goat the winner as 67
percent in 76 to victory at 4-way poll
is the borderlands is the old G and
paved the way group coming in at second
place at 16% was destiny no one does Lou
and gunplay better group and third place
at 10% was division the gear set and
loot mid max King and sadly at only 7%
was the I don't care it's media bias if
anthem isn't crowned to go through the
only way to make that fares your anthem
with the division participating in last
week's poll Lords of the multiverse what
do you guys think about Orleans being
crowned the og looter shooter yeah I
mean you got ya people were wrong all
the time
Borderlands trash throw it in the bushes
get rid of it yeah I mean I was I was
never really that big of a fan of
snorter lands myself I'm not the biggest
fan of borderlines but you guys want to
calm down okay it's not that bad look
over here Paul trying to sit there come
back Borderlands get out of here I'm a
poorly run I'm gonna borrow a line from
a Nick here so the only reason the only
way I would be interested in a bore
Lance
there was some magician dlc i played
Borderlands 2 I was ok that's about it
the old is he going in he said cut a
Mike's throw them all off the panel I
don't want here nothing he just sniped
you at the longbow on apex that's what
he just did you know I played the
original one when I got my ps3 but I
just couldn't get into it nah I couldn't
fail you don't really get into it it's a
tough crowd it's a tough panel to dig
though the lows who participated man
we're getting today we're gonna have
another ALP Twitter cooking up so I'm
actually before we get into these topics
on some breaking news even sent from the
realm of Google I got a chance to look
at that first controller I don't know if
you guys got a chance to see it man
mock-up going on so uh I just want to
the row man what do we think about on a
screen share that crash because uh I was
actually surprised to be honest that
deep we're all actually gonna do this I
would I would give that to you right
there in a second this is baby alright
there's a bad boy right here yeah looks
like so it looks like the DualShock 3
from the ps3 had a baby with yuck you
know what that really does look like we
like fallout 76 players playing that's
what you guys playing that oh man that's
the only way it runs ATO plate with that
controller it's 60 frames isn't an
anchorman is that what you have Nami go
whatever
ergonomic it doesn't look like it's like
form-fitting to your hand like it's
forcing your hand most like the handles
could be used as a blunt object to kill
ya I mean if that's true the controller
they clearly didn't do focus groups with
with human hands I mean front of these
proportions or off so this is a mock-up
oh this this particular thing looks at
they said what's the worst possible
thing we could possibly take from every
controller right we have tiny little
stakes from the switch and we're gonna
have we're fixin the worst possible
location for the distribution shock
Riddler and then if you look right and
go it just looks like Sony and Microsoft
got together and tried to slander them
that's like let's start a fire before
they get it started you know if you look
at the diagram know what's interesting
about it is is the fact that it is it is
a Sony form factor that we talked about
how regardless of Google's reach right
they have a huge reach that it might
behoove them to get in bed with somebody
in the gaming space and push whatever
their their cloud initiative was right
ain't no for me and I think a lot of
people this way I think
the Xbox controller setup is objectively
the better setup so for them to
specifically go with something that
resembles a DualShock is interesting to
me okay the only thing about that though
is they don't have the trackpad at all
got out the salty said it look like a
controller from the dollar store dams
but if you're gonna copy anything you
copied a market leader I don't care
anybody get sitting in say Xbox says the
greatest control around the world it
doesn't sell 100 million so obviously
the controller and all that so getting
right back to that the PlayStation is
winning right now so of course you're
gonna copy if you're getting into a
space you're gonna copy who's the best
you're gonna look at the systems I'm
pretty sure that the system might look
like a PlayStation 4 when it comes out
probably some context so pretty much
that this is the patent that was filed
that initial mock-up and obviously it's
leaked before GDC way it looks like they
intended to show this thing so um you
know as we slowly look like it had like
the Google put as his speech things off
wait
right you know what do we feel about
this just from a hardware standpoint
that they're looking to be serious to
have hardware for project speak well the
thing about it is they kind of have no
choice now right because they're getting
into a space that like a lot of people
getting into right now to Verizon you
know obviously Microsoft
so again if they could only pair up with
somebody who's already not announced
anything specific in that space or just
do their own thing like right now
obviously an Xbox controller is gonna
work the project stream just fine but
they they have to give some branding to
their product or else it you risk it
getting sort of lost in the shuffle
right though because beyond the
controller I don't think they've said
anything about a specific box for them
besides it's just a streaming service
you can access anywhere right matter the
box wouldn't matter
right beegley correct sir yeah so yeah
you have to have you have to find
something to brand you know project
stream with so a controller anchor like
what do you think they're like in
general do you do you take that take a
big they're taking it really serious now
like where's your whole thought process
with them trying into the game look at
the console game again and it really
depends how I go about doing this lis I
mean party addition there so far is that
if they were trying to leo jump on
somebody else like jump on the switch
and be their streaming platform whatever
like that that would make sense but
they're going with this own entirely
separate route which lately google
jumping into something entirely alone
has not been great when they were trying
to become an in a certain isp right when
they were to go down that route it it's
not been going too hot for them right
now
but with cloud backing just a big
presence you you're not taking them
serious as a thread or like just a
general you're just like wait and see
what's your overall feeling in these
early stages of you hearing them trying
to get flipped again right now until I
start seeing some actual games they're
gonna start pushing and they're gonna
start developing I think they're just
gonna use this more as like a mobile
mobile gaming platform a you have some
easy games where it doesn't require
vast amounts of skill or geographical
output I think the biggest thing that
factors into Google coming in is the
controller and what the games are I
don't think the games are gonna be an
issue because at the end of the day
Google when they go into a field they
just don't go and you know fill it out
they go and be like okay here's a
million dollars here's a million dollars
okay you need 20 here's 20 like they
don't have a problem going in opening
like a blank check right other thing is
is that I think the controller might be
a drop though because as you can already
see like when it comes to controllers
people are really particularly over that
IO that's one of the reasons I won't
play on PlayStation from time up and
it's it's it's confirmed that it's not
proportionate like so we can't hold that
one we just show it to the letter of the
law already looks like a playstation
controller so I'm not down oh so you
already did because of the Antelope play
I don't win analogs like that I just
don't watch it beat you there's actual
multiple controller styles see I would
be ok with that
yeah but at the end of the day like
people will sit here acting like Google
can't computer games they're delusional
Google has no problem going to a big
publisher and just buying the whole
publisher like that that's the kind of
money Google does every time they do not
they don't do it half they go in there
full force and buy whatever they can
they they they kick doors open with
money they don't care what do you think
it yeah good good I think that's one of
the reasons Microsoft's buying so many
you know mid tier studios is because
they know Google is about to come in and
then I could we don't buy it now Google
is gonna buy it
mmm what do you think on dead man would
you see any stuff and just how serious
are you taking Google right now well
Google is access 100 correct they kick
in the door look at how they picked up
YouTube they just went here's like
billions of dollars we're gonna buy this
this site right up thing is that after
Google buy something they run it right
into the ground every damn time look at
this as a point you can't even get out
of customer service for you to you look
at YouTube okay a perfect example
everything going on they can't control
the content that's on kids YouTube
you've got like or things going on with
kid
YouTube you got them D monetizing
content creators because of their
comments section it's just unreal and
how it's handled YouTube is and that's
only one thing look at all the stuff
Google closes down they'll buy something
get into in a year layer go yeah now
it's Google+ Google anything they put
their name to if it doesn't make them
all their money back they investing in a
year they dumped it like I just want to
cut you for one second I'm dead
in this sense I shot tube wrapped in an
in the chat he actually made a point
bringing in on Phil Harrison was at the
former Sony / former Xbox exact into
their gaming division does that even
give you any cause there's two things
they're gonna kill this console a that
controller because you know what if it's
like if it's anything I always say I
always tell people I don't like
PlayStation controls they're too small
they're like oh well the do shark force
perks I look this thing in my hand made
for a child I play with I play with the
Duke controller because that feels like
a normal control over my head dude you
are free for each man Evan sir like
maybe if they bring out something that's
the size of DualShock 3 and anyone that
played on ps3
that's real with themselves will admit
that the ps3 controller felt like flimsy
tiny garbage duel junk duel shark or is
exponentially better than - do you know
I know you know what i'ma say imma say
this right in defense of Sony's
controller when we was playing on those
stupid little Nintendo square boxes and
Sony came out with a controller
everybody stood up and shook their hands
it was like hell yeah don't when it came
out with the dual analog everybody was
champion son oh my god
then with Microsoft came out with their
controller and they switched up the the
analogues and I said okay it made sense
and now we got to a point where it makes
sense but don't front like them Sony
controllers wasn't that thing from all
those we control the DualShock and the
DualShock to which came with the ps2
those were great controllers there was
something very cheap feeling about the
DualShock 3 there the sixaxis thing yeah
that was inside the controller before
when he was able to tilt control and
yeah but let's now for like Sony didn't
have really good control Ibiza 3 was
only my ever complaint the big thing
with Google is a lot of people are
hesitant about Google entering the
market were they gonna bring everything
else they could come in buy a bunch of
studios but who wants to go I'd say
Google offers a $500 home console so you
buy a $500 Google doing any of that is
creaming it you you guys you guys that I
don't know if you guys are under the
impression that they're you're getting a
console as well this is just project
stream and I think that's all they're
doing $100 piece of hardware piece of
hardware that Google's get support for
no I think this is really just an app it
really is just accessing their servers
and that's their you know Google isn't
every day and we're like any night lost
I'm pick up my phone I'm like Google
isn't good I'm gonna tell you right now
y'all think it's a joke Amazon and
Google wants to be afraid of these guys
are going to move into the space and
then I'm going to spread like a virus if
you haven't played a Assassin's Creed
I'm telling you that the leader
streaming that I thought was in video ok
because I was playing it in Nvidia
shields all the iterations we talked
about that last night and I thought they
had an infrastructure that was so
dominant that I thought the Nintendo was
going to take over over that space and
used
utilize what they had with them
I was sad that they didn't do that but
to see Google in this short period of
time cover so much ground in just a
browser that is scary
and I know Microsoft saw it and
Microsoft started pushing this
initiative to get these studios to start
pushing out this content to push this
cloud forward because if they get into
this space it's going to be everywhere
and it's gonna be effortless I mean I
think the difference between that though
is Amazon is the one to fear more than
Google okay because and the Internet
infrastructure at this point in time is
still not beneficial enough where Google
could actually really make a splash
immediately right Amazon they could
where they can go both routes streaming
and physical in the short term just just
imagine for a moment the Amazon gets in
the thing and they actually do have
physical get it this or whatever reason
free delivery your game yeah the day
before it comes out they can ensure that
they can ensure that because they'd be
the publisher it's not like it's not
like they have like a limitation where
it's like okay yeah we'll put the game
out it's gonna come out March 20th but
if you get it on you get a day before
him because early shipping whatever but
they can actually ensure that you get it
early because they be controlling the
street launch date let me let me ask you
guys this and I you you actually alluded
to what I want to say Hank it was in
sense of do you think that it's a
mistake if a project stream with Google
doesn't have the option to download
these games to like a harddrive console
it's extremely exclusive like Mike where
do you feel where firs I'm like where
you have with this whole Google thing
yeah all I gotta say is if I see anybody
standing for a Google console I don't
care if it's hard our box
500 bucks you're getting exposed because
all I heard in 2013 the Xbox one came
out was all connect they're watching you
they're listening for you all the time
so you're gonna have a problem with that
right but you're not gonna have a
problem with Google tracking what you're
playing when you're playing it how long
you're playing it for and then using
that information that's to said targeted
ads for you you're getting exposed
with my eyesight you'll be playing
Resident Evil and it's gonna be like oh
you were interested in our blue green
herbs product placement exactly so but
you're not even you're not taking them
serious you don't where you're just like
oh you're not feeling it like when I
mean I have to see more as far as like
what games they're coming out with what
publishers they're bringing on board you
know I think every time a company as big
as Google launches a new endeavor you
have to take them seriously but to see
them going up against you know Sony
which you know they're rolling out
remote play two phones and stuff we'll
see where that goes from there and
Microsoft with their ex cloud I mean the
competition stiff and those companies
have really diverse portfolio is in
gaming and Google still got to build
that up a little bit so it remains to be
seen type of thing absolutely I mean I
think we should transition right there
Mike set it up real good in reference to
you know obviously Sony and stuff I mean
as far I agree with all you guys know
Penn as far as on Google I it's I'm more
on a wait-and-see you know with this
whole project stream we've solvers
actually tested it and so if you
actually felt really good about what you
play for mr. right yeah super good I
said yeah the conditions had to be ideal
right um but I had ideal conditions for
PS now I had ideal conditions for you
know um on live back in the day and that
didn't even come close to what I played
with with AC Odyssey on project streams
so I'm really excited what they can do
and another thing we haven't talked
about is what you know what their plans
aren't 5g because sure their plans
include 5g it's not just hard wired
connections so that's another thing that
needs to be considered with these guys
like I don't really think I know you
mentioned specifically about you know
what is it a mistake not to have
downloads available that that could
definitely be an option for them but I
think they're going they're going
full-tilt into the streaming thing and I
think they're leaning into like super
high-end high speed connected networks
in addition to you know whatever 5g
brings to the table so I don't I think
they trying to get into this with as
little overhead as possible I think the
controller is honestly the extent of the
hardware that you see mm-hmm okay okay
I'm with Google's I don't I don't see
purely just streaming as a true
alternative because what we're
forgetting is a lot of Middle America
has data caps right like they they had
data caps and they can't do anything for
us tomorrow if they make anyone that can
work around it it's going to be Google
no for you guys because you guys are in
the States versus why I am up here this
will not have its own ISP stateside or
delay their hunts from a Google Fiber
it's not everywhere see this talking
about earlier when Google wanna get into
the ISP game with Google Fiber they had
a lot of momentum at first but what they
realize is that a lot of the
infrastructure for making fiber-optic
cables and stuff was dominated in
certain areas by the local ISPs good and
so they can't do anything but they won't
let that have access to any of the
utility frameworks if he was looking at
any of the super pacs that was being
pushed through the political stuff I
don't do political stuff too much but if
he was looking at any of the super PACs
that was being pushed through a Verizon
and other larger networks was actually
uh stomping their growth so again they
try to get into another sector if that
bill wasn't passed under the table it
didn't get through so it was very
limited and where you got Google Fiber
at that was because they they were
playing hardball with the big guys all
right so yeah when you try to get into
territories that are dominated by the
mainstream
you're not gonna infiltrate unless this
you're greasing palms and I guess today
is the right forum so it's not even
rather that grease and problems when you
try to go into local I wanted to have
talked about this heavy yeah you go no
you know localizing any kind of they
have a lot more relationships you know
Verizon deals with people in this area a
lot more there are a lot of these
political politicians and stuff they're
gonna go with them over Google that that
doesn't even have a groundwork in this
area and all they're trying to get in it
but they're like you know Verizon over
here has been helping me get elected
every year for the past five years
for no moms yeah I want to bring up a
good point shout this thing any chat man
he's concerned about cellphone providers
he thinks that they will drop unlimited
data in a heartbeat over this like they
can right oh oh you guys get unlimited
cell phone data yeah like I for me like
my cell phone bill is $130 for many now
how it works though is that it's it's
it's unlimited but it's like you you had
they'll give you a certain amount of
data and before there but once you cross
a certain threshold they'll throttle you
down to like you know the hell out of us
alright with that because like I got
bail 5 which is 1 gigabyte down length
hundred up by only pay fifty three
dollars for that joint so what the
problem is is a long time ago you know a
bunch of people got into a room and
aggrieved who gets what district what
gets what district and for the past
twenty years that's what we've been
going by yeah man this is interesting
matter I'm glad notices breaking news
kind of had to talk about it in the game
but we got some Sony news to get into
yeah man news came out man PlayStation
firmware 6.50 was released and it makes
a Sony or Remote Play service to be
available on iOS devices so your phone
your tablet now formerly this was on the
Vita when it existed so shout to the
veena owner shout undead music it was
relevant you know and it was out there
this has been causing some gamers to you
know have some discussions amongst
themselves and you know a lot of cloud
talk and PS now talk and remote play
talk so I want to bring this to the
roundtable start with anchorman with
this coming to ps4 on iOS devices what
do you think about it I think some
people are blowing it way out of
proportion
it's not even remotely close to the
little game past discussion we've been
having it's not the same thing
but I mean it is
like right now it's not on the same
level but come on guys you know what's
gonna happen all right we do agree I can
write from a standpoint that this is
nothing new they've had remote play
before but the issue is the fact that
now it's going to iOS devices your
feeling is that this is kind of like the
precursor estep to possibly setting up
something in the future with some
expanding guys there was an interview
with Yoshida back in 2013
I remember reading it I remember walking
back from class or exactly where I was
when I read it
Yoshida was talking about how the next
PlayStation there may be a box but the
future is streaming and every single
action they've taken this entire
generation has been setting up streaming
mmm the future and what's funny
yeah Sony's what are you reading and
what Sony every action there's been said
enough every action they have taken this
generation has been building towards
dreaming see what it is is they low-key
like put their put their foot in the
water they're like you know let's see
like Microsoft ride to jump in and they
just put their foot in the water okay
let's let's do this PlayStation now
thing and then when Microsoft's okay
after Microsoft finally got out about
that River after almost drowning to
death they're like all right now let's
try game past this seems like a safe bet
let's let them download their games and
then you know after a positive reception
with that Sony's oh they got something
okay can we make the ps4 games
downloadable oh we can't go do that then
let's get everybody else idiot Lord
might be the truth what do you think
about ps4 remote play on iOS devices is
this setting something else up so I mean
I think PS now on mobile devices is
inevitable right because they they've
they've already had remote play going
you guys have already said that but you
have to look at it from sony's
perspective they're testing it on other
devices that are non Sony devices now
right so with remote play they're trying
to work out okay what's the streaming
quality going to look like on different
screen sizes and you know if somebody's
playing on an iPhone or if it's
iPad you can't guarantee that they're
gonna have a dual shock for and so this
is a good time for them to kind of work
out what that interface is going to look
like as far as all the buttons on the
screen how do we place how do we lay
them out if the button layout doesn't
work could we maybe do some type of
gesture controls or certain action so
this is going to be kind of like the
Graham where they test all that stuff
out want other devices and then
eventually they I do believe I think
it's inevitable they are going to roll
out PS now one multiple devices I see a
lot of people on Twitter burning up the
fact that they don't like that there's
not a physical controller like this
isn't made for us this isn't made for
the people born in our time frames this
isn't made for me anchorman or you guys
this is made for those twelve thirteen
year olds it's about to grow up in about
five six years has been playing
fortnight on the phone so I need okay
nothing let's get undead in sovereign in
here man undead what do you think man as
far as this whole you know ps4 remote
play iOS devices
you know PS now where's your whole head
space look they share rolled this way
when they had the Vita like this was do
not this was stuff that would have been
great for the video if you have rolled
PS now out onto Vita point and like
remote play on the Vita is seamless okay
that is smooth it is great it works well
they're rolling it out to mobile devices
while they count the Vita and in the
same week they have remote play to my OS
Isis it makes a lot of sense they killed
one thing that they did really well and
now they're just moving on to something
else and being able to play your games
everywhere let's face it the switch is
doing it xbox is gonna be doing it with
X cloud it's it's the wave the mobile
devices are a huge market everyone
forgets this I said this on my show last
night people forget that the mobile
market in Asia
oh you astronomical the reason why n
cent wants to come to the west and buy
up so many Studios is because they won't
make mobile versions of all the big IPS
so they can solve them in Asia because
Asia I think on the mobile markets
something like ten to one its massive
sorry
Pizza
okay Chad is with you attic on the
mobile generation completely people
don't realize that when it comes to you
know they're they like this this console
war stuff get another way like Sony is a
very smart company you know especially
this generation they know where the they
know eventually you know yeah it's all
what when it comes to innovating stuff
it's about timing you don't want to do
it too soon you want to do too late you
don't want to do too soon because the
consumer base might revolt and you want
to do it too late because then you've
already missed the way that's why the
copycat ninja it's better to copy better
than to nice that they don't what they
don't um this this week we get this on
the death nail of the Vita all right
the the V the Vita is a dead in the
water because remember they were trying
to package their PlayStation 4 with the
Vita type of thing it was trying to get
you to purchase it and we talked about
this on Daily Show
I had the 3G version was it a 3G version
or 2g version something like that of the
Vita's and I found it to be super
seamless like with my system being on at
home I was able to play my games out in
the street and I thought that was
ingenious but the fact that the Vita
died
they still had this infrastructure set
up they still had these thoughts because
they have think tanks and they have
research and development and it pour all
this money into this stuff and he mapped
this stuff out now they told the guy
okay this died how can we get this into
everybody's hands and they figured it
out software wise to get it through iOS
now I know um and Roy to probably be
next after this is conquered just this
area is conquered first right so you go
through this way and you make sure that
you get those games on to these iOS
devices now as far as Eric was saying my
son doesn't care for controller he sits
down he plays his Kindle all day long so
he plays if he can play spider-man with
touch controls on his Kindle or on you
know on his iOS he doesn't have that but
if it's on his Kindle he doesn't care
mmm and it works for him and that's the
demographic they're talking shout-out to
God
chief Tommy with the fine I love super
chat where's they have Wayne away at
topic am I the only one that wants PC
games on console ETA late May I mean we
aren't seeing you know PC games go to
one thing that I'm really looking
forward to am i picking up on PC before
it comes that Xbox cuz if they can too
long is that hard shadow game that it's
going on is it on xbox preview yet no
they don't have a date for yes I believe
she has a preview of it on our log net I
might reach out to the appropriate
people and get my hands on that cuz it
look it gives me our evolved filling but
actually done right and we that's you
actually see a lot of these games go
over to call it so uh especially Xbox
cues of their preview program arc one on
their first because of that what uh what
are those big games just went on preview
pop G was in preview for like a year it
felt like yeah hunt showdown that's what
it's called uh you know you do see PC
games go to console it's just certain PC
games physically can't be on console
because of a controller restriction no
doubt let's get out Lord sovereign him
and what what do you feel about all this
news PlayStation 4 remote play yes now
latest with the iOS devices
I think everybody's sort of hit it right
on the head um I think the fact that the
Vita was was specifically killed this
week and then coming out hand in hands I
mean again it was murdered yeah it was
me that me the island was blown up but I
just think the fact that the fact that
it's coming to iOS noggin is taking
forever
apparently for no reason but if you look
it if you look at how expanded it it
sort of is on iOS compared to then
Windows and Mac and compared to what you
have on on all Android which is still
sort of it still hasn't been expanded
very much on Android is it just like in
it doesn't only work for like Xperia
phones or something like that
some craziness like that I don't think
it works on every Android phone inferior
phones yeah
it rhymes so it's not gonna be any
Android standard here your phones okay
okay yeah ten days you know market
leaders not know so I think it's I think
it's really huge that they're working on
this now like Mikey said I think it just
means that laying the groundwork for
being able to expand on this in a really
really big way and you know anybody who
thought they weren't going this route
sorry the kids coming and they've been
the tea leaves have been there yeah you
haven't really been wanting to pay
attention but it's coming and they're
doing it in a way that suits them cuz
again I don't think they themselves have
the proper infrastructure to go full
tilt on it themselves they need partners
in this and I think you're gonna see
more of this stuff with them sort of you
know coming out on iOS expanding what
they have on Android I think this is the
way to do it um and but a sovereign
something what do you say to the
PlayStation person who was nervous and
who's afraid that they're moving away
from console like Microsoft is the
choice you're gonna get your box and
you're gonna get your single-player
experiences you're still gonna get those
about that one because that's not going
down cuz I will be playing if I can do
it I'll be playing my PlayStation games
on a piece that's question real quick
would you guys feel if they made like
PlayStation now like you can't naturally
buy these games off of the other
platforms you can only get them if you
subscribe to their you know perspectives
like game pass and like you can't buy
halo infinite on on a certain platform
but you can subscribe to game Pez and
get it from that app only now would mean
that would have to be the way that it
works again unless these guys
specifically war
out deals for titles where they're
sharing revenue like that that's the
only way that can work where it would be
you could even think about you know an
executive on the other end being okay
with you playing that game on there okay
imagine imagine you saw in Halo Infinite
unlike Nintendo and Nintendo get up from
that daddy
Sony's ultimate Jitsu is gonna be first
party games in PlayStation now it's
funny you mention that Atticus last
night we had a little bit of
conversation last night about you know
people's the the assumptions people are
making about all this Nintendo's quits
and gamepad stuff and people are like
let's look at this stuff logically right
let's look at it logically just can this
stuff just really live on there the way
it is now right it's that would not make
sense to any executive looking at that
like no hell no so it it's I don't think
it's quite the way that we expect it to
be or the way we've been talking about
that it can be mm-hmm
this is interested yeah listen this is
nothing new to me I mean like like
undead said they had the Remote Play
feature for Vita for the longest I was a
big proponent used it all the time the
only thing is it wasn't obviously like
pure streaming because basically you it
turns your ps4 on remotely and due to
mirror the inputs for my meter and you
know and then play it was super solid I
did like it not unlike I did also though
I had some issues though it wasn't like
there was some lag so have I tried to
play like Killzone or something like man
like any type of fast twitch so they it
was strictly made for a first player
experience just like all their games oh
you don't say but if you want to play
like a standard you know single play
games everyday you could do it you don't
say iOS devices on it this is just an
extension of it to me and it's to me it
just shows that you're both Sony and
Microsoft want to get that service and
yes services and their cloud services on
multiple multiple devices and I think
that's gonna be the same thing with PS
now I think that is literally coming I
mean and correct me if I'm wrong so if
they actually had OH
have that cloud engineering team job
listing for him being serviced and it
literally states to any device so those
who are being resistant of this changed
it's just where these companies are
going you know think okay one is being
open and honest and the other one are
you saying Microsoft like walking all
play in the field and is in the Metal
Gear Solid box in defense 30 was doing
it first will remote play come on y'all
this right Mike if they're what's in the
library Microsoft will be an open book
Sony try to give you the impression and
maybe this was this was how it was in
the beginning but right the remote play
would still be isolated to their walled
garden right then as things have changed
you realize that that's that's an
archaic way to think you can't I think
Jim Ryan has been taken into a back room
and it explained what he has to do just
looking from a standpoint Sony's get
putting himself in the situation to
where they won't be last in the market
they won't be first by any means but
they won't be last because they were
first on this and then we gotta be clear
now like Sony was first a shout out to
sting in a chat as far as dumb or
streaming the PC as well they weren't
technically first Microsoft may have the
better infrastructure and Azure they
doing it I guess it would stand point
where you know they were going 90 in the
50 at first and then like all I'm but to
get pulled over say they slowed down and
now they going 40 in a 50 and what and
when they see that you know that the
second place about the past them they're
like okay now we'll go speed back up the
way that's gonna happen is all these get
all these games we're gonna be able to
play all these games wherever you want
whenever you want everything else and
all these console warriors there
Twitter right now or they're gonna have
a a meetings for cats they're gonna be
like hi my name is I'm a Toys R Us kid
so my soul is young someone someone
retweeted something in my feed and
someone's like if Sega was sold the
console market none of this would ever
have happened they would have like five
different versions of the same thing
each more inferior to the next we bring
this one cuz I've seen this a lot and
I've seen any chat with we've all in
agreement on the panel that this is the
direction both Microsoft and Sony's
going so my question then is we keep now
I'm starting to see oh well this means
consoles are going away what do we feel
about that quickly I think there always
be yeah I think that sooner or later
you're gonna get to a point where
internet is where it needs to be you'll
have the the main platforms like like
Microsoft Sony and then you have
third-party streaming platforms that
stream from all of them it's like kind
of like a Roku thing I think like you
know 10 years down the ride
look Road you're gonna see you know apps
and you know third-party apps that will
let your string from all the services
hmm so you still think consoles always
gonna be me here
anchorman what about your consoles here
yes they don't leave yet the consoles
will become like arcade boxes yeah so
you think they're out of here like I
mean they're gone I'm sure there's gonna
be some person out there is gonna go
spend thousand dollars go get it yeah I
got I gotta have my n64 experience but
the markets like you start with the data
caps and make that reinterpretations
some limitations it eventually will get
to that point okay
I mean you're there so I'm just gonna
come down to is you know no one's really
pushing against against the Machine
right now no one besides you know
certain people but when Sony Microsoft
go
they need those restrictions approached
when used to have multiple billion
dollar corporations pushing against
machines something's gonna break
absolutely Lord King consoles going away
yes enough good it did
Wow did um you're gonna probably see
this is gonna be Microsoft last big
system the place they've been at then
they're definitely making more systems
after yeah they definitely making more
systems they're gonna be called surface
pros and Pro X and you know iOS get your
new phones with the game pass on it um
I'm telling you right that's hardware
right okay guys remember what I told you
they're building these servers out here
for a reason they're not building it for
show now okay I gotta correct
in those servers or Xbox hard wiggle on
your program is not gonna be your living
room your hardware isn't your controller
hardware mmm
so you're gonna have your controller and
your controller is gonna bluetooth to
your television and you're gonna play
that way okay my crew of consoles going
away yes or no sir I don't think they're
going away within like the next 5 10
maybe even 15 years or anything like
that because right now you're still not
gonna be able to replicate the fidelity
and the responsiveness of gaming on an
actual box not right now but I do think
eventually you know as broadband
infrastructure improves once they really
start rolling 5g out eventually we are
gonna reach a point where I think it's
not going to be as much of a difference
whether there's gonna be so small you're
not gonna be able to notice it and I
think maybe within I would say the next
two three generations modules are
probably going by that - my question
yeah all right you said five years right
yeah we saying the next Tasos no launch
in 2020 right mmm right all right so
that's when that generation starts so
you're gonna say 2025 right Brad all
right so 2025 you don't think that
consoles is gonna be in the bushes I
don't I don't think I don't I don't
eventually I don't think it's gonna be
that quick chuckle I think I think
- sure I don't think it's gonna be that
fast we're gonna have to get to a point
where your phone can you know you just
giving a hotspot you give the same kind
of Internet that a fiber internet would
give you right
5g if I tell you how did you say come
out if I saw what I mean yeah I think I
I think in the long term like we're
always going there's always going to be
a superior way to play your game locally
right I don't know that it's a box
anymore and I don't know but I agree
Mike I think it's 15 to 20 years down
the line I don't think we're quite there
yet but I think eventually that happens
but you'll always have a superior local
way to play the game but I think and
this will always just be a choice it'll
always just be an option I don't know
that it ever completely takes over for
that specific reason I think local
fidelity is always you know when I say a
hundred percent that we're gonna get
there quick is one physical media dies
completely mmm interesting because we're
not the digital I feel like that's when
everyone's gonna be pushing for it I
mean your dad man he chomping at the bit
man he's ready to jump in yeah well they
did look we said bye everyone and all
those influencers and everything else
back in 2012 say console markets dead
it's gonna be gone by 2018 they said and
look where we are now we got 100 million
ps4s for a million Xbox wide and we've
got the switch who's absolutely going
against every grain of reality that has
a console console are gonna go away I
agree with Mike you were looking at like
a 15 to 20 year timeline however mmm
the day that I can play playstation
games Xbox games and I'm holding out for
Nintendo games the day I natively
download those onto my PC my consoles
are going out the window I don't
honestly II truly believe that
Nintendo's never leave in that market
they're always gonna have some kind of
portable
column from Lord Rings they're gonna be
sitting in the corner like now take it
from us we
yeah I'll be doing that but that's fine
but like I've said this before I love
the flexibility of PC gaming but the
thing is all my friends play on Xbox or
Playstation so those are the consoles I
play mmm when the market starts to
change my friends will follow where the
market goes and that's where I'll
eventually go I don't have a loyalty to
any of the box I don't think any of the
boxes are going anywhere anytime soon
like I said likes it's been mentioned
before internet quality and everything
else isn't the same everywhere like if
anyone's ever been to Europe there it is
like you ask people in Britain what
their internet qualities like and
they're like yeah I like my two
megabytes per second finish up I'm sorry
it is what it is
things are gonna change and it's the
same thing as I remember when like why I
was a kid people like oh man I don't
understand this disc stuff like why
would you ever go away from a cartridge
it makes no sense can you scratch so
easy a cartridge you can throw it at
your mom's head and I'm still be like
great thing about cartridges but we all
shifted away dude shift at the disc
Sony's coach that innovation through
Xbox follow through and now we're on
discs and Nintendo is still on
cartridges yeah you know how I know that
King and I right cuz I'm not gonna even
talk about that I want one pair you guys
be acting like I've lost every bit of
thematic to braid here hey that kids
smooth levels what I can't why can't we
ever bring up when more King David lost
to Lisp red no no no no I stood this huh
you won but you don't see me breathing
this I still have your knees
so you're saying there's bushes in your
house yes you might need to get that
took you care you gotta get some Garvey
or something at some point you probably
will get there just don't think it's
anytime soon until the infrastructure is
in place and obviously you want if you
want the highest fidelity you want the
best place to play it's going to be on
dedicated platform it's always there my
opinion gonna be an option so people
want to get their premium experience but
once infrastructures rise once five g's
in place and you know again on a global
scale I don't know if everyone can be
accommodated but I still think the
option is gonna be there so we shall see
a lot of tech and stuff to talk about it
Lord addict what for this give you an
even live when you publicly say fallout
76 came out buggies also teasers came
out buggy as hell
some water due to Indiana Mandela water
but ok anyway so right now you know a
couple months ago I don't even know how
long ago it was but Sony actually
announced that they weren't going to be
e3 people claim I was actually one of
them saying you know this isn't a huge
like the the thing is people want to say
III was dead I didn't necessarily think
it was dead I just thought you know it's
not as impactful as it used to be just
because you know Sony's not going to be
that doesn't mean the whole platforms
dead but now it's looking like e a isn't
gonna be there to and EA already kind of
left it a little bit with the EA play
are they gonna do an EA play they are
doing Annie a plane is confirmed and
what we've heard right now is they are
doing it's a little different and it's
in self they're not gonna do a press
conference but they're gonna be doing
some live multi
while they're there so they're gonna
have some presents so what I want to
bring to the the round table was a first
off on one ask two questions one do you
think e3 is dead do you think that next
year you know Microsoft might pull up
because I feel like the reason Microsoft
you didn't even consider it is because
they saw that as an opportunity do you
think with inside Xbox as it starts to
grow and starts to grow as a platform do
you think they might pull away announce
was from e3 to spread on all of the
inside Xbox go more towards an insta you
know a focus like you know what Nintendo
does and my second question is do you
think EA true intentions are not being
there is they didn't have nothing to
show because they've canceled most a lot
of their projects besides the they could
go on there I guess and theoretically
they can just show you a bunch of sports
but you know they've done that a lot
they got clowned on for their last
year's do you think that but another
thing is you know titanfall 3 that's not
there so it's kind of weird that they
didn't have an ether do you think that
e.a just doesn't have nothing to show do
you what do you think is the reason that
they gotta pay the bill total lives like
you should have the Lord Vogel's Krieg
he said I got a raise a phone to on sale
for the 500 save 300 and I'm ready for
this cloud streaming can't wait to play
my xbox games too I just need the razor
phone - is that is one hell yes yes yes
yes okay this is check it out check it
out
da play is still gonna be there alright
so they already made the commitment all
right this is this is how they are not
like Sony all right this is how they're
not like so and Sony's not gonna be due
at all facts okay so
also if your Sony fan you what you
thought that banner was gonna be out
there waiting greatness greatness is in
the bushes Oh baby I'm not showing up
they will be there with EA blade you
know how EA play do you play is a big
part of the first inaugural weekend and
getting you into e3 so if you ever been
to e3 and you try to get there just for
that Monday to the foot to the Thursday
you are missing out on EA play which
have artists there they have live
concerts to have playing or new games
there they have beverages shirts
everything this is a nice extravaganza
they are still committed to e3 listen
with all the stuff going on with anthem
with all the stuff they're surrounding
them with cancellations of games and I
am happy that another card one of these
fake developers no don't go Bella listen
they don't need our press conference all
I've been saying this for the longest
you hate with developer does a press
conferences or stuff starts to go right
back to showcasing your games and paying
that money to have them on Microsoft
Sony and Nintendo you don't need we
don't care to hear from you we don't
want to hear your voice put your best
foot forward put your games on these
peoples platform and just shut up and
just let those games we playing we don't
want ever watch your shows I swear I'm
so yeah I know I know for a fact you
fraud and because we watched uh you
bought us movies at e3 okay what
happened what did I do
I tuned it we're done you ever been a
fan Oh but to be fair you beasts are
listed Ubisoft does pretty much show the
same stuff every year like literally
every year they show the rainbow new
expansion coming out in the fall
they show the 400 expansion coming out
the father okay this is the new coke
we're giving you next year the day in
the show for what is 3 what do they give
you back this is what you got back when
you found out this new information right
there shows is usually how long like an
hour and a half maybe two hours got back
an hour and a half or two hours of
quality lifetime to hell with them yeah
I think I think with the issues with DEA
is like they even every since they've
tried to do a show they have never
gotten props for their show I can't
remember they have made bad calls for
whatever reason you like what the one I
think of like what was the last time it
was like why do you have all these
YouTube personalities for a live stream
why do you have la on your on your stage
I will give them the one that the unit
they had a Dragon Age Inquisition
without a strong strong one
they play though I kind of remembers
missile law it was kind of revered
because didn't and I believe Dragons
aged one game of the year that year the
fire fire yeah what given years of pity
Oh Mike yeah that wasn't so hear you any
other reasons why as far as this whole
EA thing nobody real this is my first
III I'm going I'm scheduled in I got all
that lined up but I really have like
everyone was like one of my friends has
been doing this event for like seven
years agent looks at me and goes man
he's like you're gonna want pack a
pillow if you go to EAS conference cuz
he's like it's boring nobody wants to be
here but we're here because we have to
be they cancelled the conference I'll go
to EA play I'll do that I'll chop it up
that way but their conference is like
does they will remember last year where
they sat down they're like we have a
command & Conquer game mobile mobile so
we're gonna bring a to professional
mobile gamers which we don't want to put
on your PC or console we're gonna
announce the remaster for those games
four months
later but here's a mobile game and watch
us play a full mobile game for ten
minutes nobody wants to see that he's
got nothing to show
they've got grease on Star Wars game
which they're already revealing before
e3 and as Attucks said they cancel
everything else no hey hey
anyone else on this is reasoning for I
just don't have anything to show
I mean Dragon Age is Dragon Age is
barely being worked on now that's a
next-gen game that's that's not even
remotely ready so what are they gonna
talk about anthem DLC season two stuff
or whatever I don't think about anthem
at all right yeah we have to but you
know and then you know battlefield stuff
let's say let's say they do release the
battle field of battle royale stuff it's
actually hot and people love it like
obvi did you know you're gonna want to
talk about that stuff so they're in
whatever whatever respawns new thing new
titanfall thing is it's supposedly
coming later this year
do they have stuff to talk about but I
don't think it's enough to Jedi game
right and they're also doing the game
what about I mean what about the
argument that um you know apex Legends
is such a good place and dominant for
them right now like that they could talk
about that releasing content get the
base Connor
they can run they can run a Nintendo
Direct style video right from be a play
and be like yeah I guess what you can
play it in a few minutes like you know
yeah so they're so you can play you can
play it on the show floor um you know
whatever went when the show floor or
exact you know stuff like that I think
they can just do I just don't think they
have enough to really warrant a press
conference and like everybody said like
the ones in the past have been
underwhelming there's no reason for it
not you Mike did you get in because I
don't know yeah I mean it's it's like
everybody said I mean they honestly they
really don't have much to show just like
Sony doesn't really have enough to show
so they're not going to spend resources
to do an e3 show and if they really
don't have anything and I think we're
starting to see a shift now with
companies where if they do have
something coming down the line they're
able to announce that and other venues
the
like a tweet or a quick video or a
direct or something like that and they
could generate height without having to
do the whole III thing yeah I think that
they are going to do something around e3
I don't think it's gonna be confirmed
again I don't think it's gonna be like
Sony situation could say Sony's like we
go be there we ain't gonna be around we
will even turn that stuff off we just go
sit at our house you know that's all but
I think EEA is his mindset is okay we're
going to be there we have the you know
we've already stepped away from the
floor the show for we might as well just
do something our own thing and not even
be part of that at all yeah listen man I
I hate I think hey I agree addict it is
a little different it says state like I
said it gonna have some presence as
opposed to Sony not being there
completely you know multi-stream but I
agree with you know most you guys aren't
apparent mean I think it's like one of
these things where they looking at it
from a financial standpoint and this
saves them money I guess instead of
having a traditional press conference so
I think I'm like the only one who kind
of liked a little stupid press
conference I used to like to you know
loo sports games or whatever they I was
that was that were clash your when I was
I was on the phone side dish knows
what's in there and I let it slip I was
watching oh my gosh he's like oh she's
like oh honey I'll go ahead and get off
for you so you can watch I was like
don't worry it's just yeah III in
general yeah I mean outside of a
Microsoft and Sony has only ever been to
publishers who actually made your like
it worth your time right it was you've
got stuff to show there's a bad job of
showing it I mean always brings
something to the table at least make it
work we gotta give a good at arguing
that they usually have games to show or
buy always the same thing it's here's
our sports titles plots one game baby
knows when you go to Cali and you go to
Bethesda anything from beginning to end
they know how to party and if they don't
know how to put out a good game
okay know how to come and maybe they
should stop partying coming he did not
see that coming that was a hell of a
blow good show but yeah I'm old school
man it's sad to me that uh these guys
are not EAS OD not gonna go you know and
it shows like like Atticus a and maybe
this is the direction you don't
understand this thing yeah let's stop
associating it with sony sony is doing
something a disservice to their fans
let's stop associating what they're
doing in you know you have a lot of sony
fan saying see I told you I told you
that III is not what the hell which you
it is still gonna be there they might
not be their conference wise you could
go somewhere if you're there here's the
thing like III it used to be about the
industry now it's about the industry and
the fans and Saudis like we're just not
gonna look we're not gonna even be
present for our friends and and for the
actual people that say they don't need
to be there how is the the that called
the leading industry the leading
platform not at the biggest conference
of the year like it makes no sense even
if they were just on the show floor
that's no better than not being there at
all you know I mean we've asked a
question before though do you guys
really think they don't make a single
announcement that whole week to try to
take no they're not doing a comment if
the last of us rumors true I think they
might drop a trailer that week but they
exactly know you'll make an announcement
of something that way the solver right
after the Microsoft the hell with your
brother's announcement look at the guy
that took his $500 flying in and got his
hotel or his air B&B and he's ready he's
happy the Sony dude
really don't know anything that's really
not in the Twitterverse I'm gonna go to
i'ma get there yeah they are not there
in any formal capacity you know I
understand that a lot of Sony people
this trust me guys when I went there I
was in that Sony booth I was all over
that Sony stuff I saw a flute guy I saw
all of I was there you know if you think
I'm talking from a standpoint of an xbox
do I'm talking from a standpoint of a
gamer and somebody who's paying his
hard-earned dollars to go out to Cali to
get the best experience and bring you
back that stuff if you're at work and
you're tuning in to Lords a gaming
Network and you're tuning in to ILP on
YouTube and you're trying to get these
videos you're trying to be there in
spirit I'm just gonna give you the most
out of your viewing pleasure right so if
I can't show you the games from a
company that you love who does that hurt
that hurts you hmm the for the fact that
data they not at all
that tells you something that they don't
respect your dollars mmm okay back in on
this you know what the biggest
disservice to me was when Sony pulled
out of e3 I went okay you want to do
your own event you want show Hardware
stuffs cooking in the oven I get that
because III is an industry event that's
what it was made for it's switching it's
switching gears it's a transitional
period they need to figure that out
the biggest disrespect and what made me
sad as a video game fan was he mad
people that said when Sony cancelled PSX
and said oh it's fine it doesn't matter
we don't have ATS showed that event was
only about the fans that these
developers and their fans interacting
and everything else as a PlayStation fan
you shouldn't be centered on yeah that's
fine I don't need go PS X I don't want
to meet Cory bar lock I don't want to
talk about God war I don't want to see I
don't want to get my hands on any of
these games that is a disservice to your
fan base then that's the keys
like they're about to starve you for a
year and a half
mm-hmm think about that mm-hmm they're
out there about was a lady didn't
counseling cancel you three Laster they
canceled PSX last year mmm another
cancel III and now your little PSX next
year okay let me let me bring this back
to you guys you guys are bringing up
valid points and I'm glad you guys
talking about this because it is
important and um what about you know the
mindset that I see that people say look
they're in such a commanding position
you know that it's better not to show
the same old things over again actually
what do you have something ready to show
them the back to kind of put out a
product what let me counter that though
the thing is is yes maybe if they
haven't had anything if they don't have
a big group announcement to show at e3 I
get that because everyone kind of
there's a backlash that I didn't quite
understand what Sony's e3 last year I
thought the pacing was horrible
no fine I know what about the fruit man
on day games they showed robando have
you removed the gimmicks behind that III
conference the games they showed were
absolute fire and what they showed off
was phenomenal
how they chose to show it off not the
best but at the end of the day like I
want to see these games I don't care if
we come out and we show off a different
trailer for the last was part - I don't
see if we care if we see goes - shushing
again I don't care if I see more death
stranding these are games I'm invested
in as a consumer I want to see these
games if you need to change your format
and do something else
- better showcase these games and
showcase these developers if you made a
panel and you did a stream where you get
Cory Baro out Hideo Kojima and all these
guys are developing these games to sit
down and talk about these games yeah
some people are gonna be like ooh this
is boring but there's gonna be waiting
on the couches no under man when they
tried that yeah session as someone who
enjoys that kind of thing though it
makes me sad to see them moving away
from that because back in 2016 I'm an
Xbox guy I'm screaming Xboxes and
communicate they don't do this they
don't do that Playstations got PSX they
got III they do Paris games week they do
Tokyo
game show what is Xbox doing now we get
an inside Xbox every month we have XO
events and they're doing III and Sony
cancels PSX isn't doing III and they're
like yeah we'll give you some blog posts
it's like they flip holes
I put dude I do low-key think Sony's
getting full of themselves like a kiosk
with go so his Schumer and you don't get
a key Asif of all the new games like The
Last of Us - you don't walk into the
showroom floor I don't care if you don't
have a press conference right you don't
get hands-on or potential Philip buyer
that's my biggest issue you don't have
to have a conference but be there for
your fan am i right I mean it's like you
have to be there for your fans show the
exclusives that you do have coming out
even if we already know what they are we
have to remember to Sony's got all the
marketing and licensing deals this gen
so you would think that they would want
to play because they have the marketing
deal with Call of Duty that they would
want to put Mauro or fair for on there
if you would last year they didn't show
no third-party stuff at their conference
last year like one game here's a
hypothetical ask though mmm-hmm what if
they're not what if they're not what
we're not getting those marketing deals
and on top of your question what happens
to the games that have the marketing
deals right and Sony doesn't have that
presence that would normally show on the
Sony stage right I've been to Tokyo that
is something they do use to get that
marketing right you know we could show
you on the biggest stage of the year
we're the leading platform we can show
you on all of our fans are tuning in for
III they're not even there mm-hmm yeah
there's Christopher Hart going in on
y'all he said it's funny
what does I can see you gonna make me
talk you see that little button the SC
word scroll is gone shout out to the
superjet shaving buddy you know it's
funny cuz of we were talking to kids
smooth about that he's like yeah and
talked about something my super chance
he's like I don't really just anything
not super Jetta you know look kids it's
you what the next topics over you are up
let's go at all the grandfather yeah I'm
gonna tell you right now grandpa is a
swindler a old-time hustler baby I'm
gonna tell you right now if you've never
seen anybody do it this boy on me
cardboard great again you see this this
right here if you think is a joke
Nintendo told you that that piece that I
put up there can be playable hey check
this out right Nintendo is entering the
VR space are you serious ki their fax
and they're gonna do it they're gonna do
it you know I gotta get in this kit with
you came what do they do in key no let
me tell you how they do it just like
Google cardboard but they do it in on
the greatest scale
what did I do it it with the greater
scale the kid you 79 mark it and you
know what you get with that what do you
get with the kid you get the complete
Lambo VR kit that includes switch
software materials to build
oh six Conroy's Oh gaggles Goggin you
got the blaster the camera you got dunno
what is that the bird
you got the wind pedal you got the
elephant and also you got a screen
holder in a safety cap that 7995 are you
gonna buy that they also have the broke
dude kit the broke do kegels for 3995
comes with the starter blaster you get
the goggles you get the blaster and also
you get the screen holder and the safety
cap Hey and if that's not enough
Nintendo's back in your pockets for the
expansion's man just go for 1995 each oh
cardboard I'm telling you right now
what's gonna happen Playstations gonna
come out with their competing the
PlayStation goggles yo they even tell
you you could turn off the fake VR and
because it's like a glorified umm well
everybody had a viewmaster when it was
alright it's doing this and they're
doing it your 7995 they really put this
out there helped me sway you gotta pay
the bills for real quick we got a
windows the only company I literally
sell people cardboard and they buy it
you know well I think we need a patreon
of keep putting together a lab a word yo
shout-out to fastback og with the Ted
Ellison which had the console was it
to the bushes gaming is gaming no matter
system exclusive play or indie hit that
like button share slow to the iron Lords
anthem 8ft I won't make a comment on
that Anthony super chat but if it wasn't
a super chat I would have said it's in
the bushes Oh toehold I gotta get undead
man all right you see that's how you get
your stuff ready so we all know why
Lavos the thing it's recycled we you
boxes the case are you saying that fight
that this stuff all we ordered too much
let's make it into a game look the first
thing i saw i log on to twitter and
jeffrey grub shadow to him on twitter he
said he has this tweet and this guy he's
got the vr set on and there's a
cardboard duct and oh could sell you
cardboard that you're gonna put your
switch in scrap it on your head to see a
720p 30 game like people like psvr HTC
bomb how can you bomb it the quickest
with the new king or king we needed to
have this answer right now is Lord
cognate on Lord sovereign buying this
your why is saw Cognito I give it the
king he went out there boil a bow he did
that with a menu he said you was a
quarter wait no hold up hold up the
bushes like this thank you really put me
inside well the best part of this is
wait till soldier boy comes out with a
plastic bag you put the switch in a
plastic bag
[Applause]
the soju were cardboard Lavo did not do
as well as we thought it was going to do
you have heard nothing from Lambo bought
a hole to hold all got afraid of a
shout-out to dizzy with the twenty five
dollar super chair should I be the king
at attic infomercial every episode going
forward thank you they love y'all Level
V or commercial your tag team for this
one this is a payback but I never said I
was getting laughs oh did you get lamb
okay they come we always say they don't
matter West which duty generation in
this this is at the very bottom of the
barrel based level today I want to see
what this looks like because the Queen's
oh the thing is like if you think about
like the low the cheapest VR headsets
are right now they're like blowing the
specs of its out of the water like this
there is no VR to this they just through
we are on the other private no we are in
it I don't know what the hell they're
gonna show you it is think this thing is
car show an empty box I used to be like
this thing's like five times one of
those little cheapest ones that you get
it like five below and it's met at a
cardboard you put it on there like a
little but you press on it there's just
an audio it's like visualize Mario yes
here's what I here's what I think is
what I think right
I think Nintendo is perfecting their
cardboard technology
21:25 when they come out with their own
streaming box is just gonna be a literal
box that those two were labo is like my
hairline but see the joke actually
winning with this that Lambo is sold out
we owed a Gamestop mm now because
they're not restocking it they actually
sell this stuff is actually being so
this little kit over cardboard one truck
I stole it it took the whole inventory
if you wait go buy another one like
little kids are actually walking around
with the with the backpack on and
they're doing the punching and I say
this is absolutely ingenious but the
fact that you selling something marketed
towards zero and you reaching cuz you
just get you get the boot every week
that's why that's why you're reaching
right now listen a vaguely Jovi this has
got to be closer key I'm not even bad at
the leg
I thought the Lambo was was was nothing
to be interested in I thought I last
through the whole commercial I was like
what is this what are they trying to do
this thing looks really cheaply made you
don't say and clearly I'm not the target
demographic do a white set lap all right
okay I'm glad to check it out now but
all jokes aside I've bet against a
switch this gen they prove me right this
thing by movie dude it's a lab of love
right now kitchen knife Xbox one Xbox
before you leave I gotta tell you low
key though every I'm watching one camera
today keeping and watching episode of
Alaskan bush people I'll be I think they
still may be okay so this is the thing
that we laugh at it because it's not for
us it's for somebody
matter of fact we had hole going to show
them behold had it or is this for his
kids good no the thing is is what what
King said is like they might get pushed
back because I can't see any real V any
anything really resembling via are being
utilizing this right people really know
what VR is like this is the thing they
can fool any damn one like you don't
know
what VR is and you give it to this
little four-year-old this little
five-year-old you play here Tommy VR
yeah and he really runs away with that
he really thinks as we are is might
change narrative we laugh it did which I
wouldn't be surprised if there MPD come
out and we see the $40 version leave it
I'm releasing the top five you know how
they do so I think Freud nobody knows
his real VR and not coming in at 35
right way not leaning the way they got
the $80 for all of them oh man my only
question is what is the actual quality
of this VR and that's the thing cuz if
kids start throwing up left and right
then you're gonna have a problem like I
mean if you think about psvr and you
need $200 headset at minimum $200
console and that is that is an OK
experience what what is this gonna give
you I don't think is what we think I
think is a viewmaster I think you
actually put it on and you actually
probably see the images in 3d and it you
know like those 3d are the pictures they
do like on Facebook yeah okay that's
cool I don't have kids actually running
around with that on running into walls
and doing all this crazy stuff
I think it's a viewmaster sit down type
of thing I think they're gonna master
this space I really honestly not I think
that I'm laughing but I think you never
know that they know so we clearly don't
pickin they are pushing this thing they
still support it we gotta see man we got
a lot of times just getting out of here
Lord solve Psych it all and uh days gone
man
amen so I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
blow of eight a little bit man cuz I'm
super super excited for these games um
so finally we start we started getting
some some gameplay previews and
embargoes are going up just first sector
oh we can actually see at least you know
an hour two hours where it's a gameplay
and you've often heard us talk on the
podcast about about channel
and Origen hire lawyers and what that
meant to us and you know again I I know
we've reiterated this a million times
but for us channel five we say
something's Channel five it takes us
back to those days Saturday afternoons
kung-fu Peter are like on Fox five like
I spent the Saturday afternoons what
just watching you know five deadly
venoms all that old stuff and every time
we saw we saw a hot fight with smooth
flowing like you know like moves and
whatnot that's Channel five does every
call and for me
sucky row is that and and it does it in
a way and what makes me super excited
about is the fact that it's it's in a
genre that has sort of gradually moved
towards continuously improving their
combat if you look at the souls games
right mmm-hmm Dark Souls the combat is
always been sort of a little bit stilted
very slow very dependent on on blocking
and then finding your openings and then
with blood-borne that evolved somewhat
where was more about the attack and
moving side-to-side and I think second
row takes that even a step further
because now it incorporates it
incorporates the defense with the
offense being right up on your opponent
deciding whether you want to parry or
whether you want a straight up attack or
whether you want to use stealth to
approach them in a way that none of
these games have ever done before
five and for me like I have there's two
universal truths that I sort of live by
and this a stupid book what you want to
make anything better you add bacon to it
or you add ninjas to it make it included
ninja on anything and you good it looks
like it looks like ten shoe reading
wrong attention on the next level the
thing is when when we originally saw one
of the first uh the first videos they
put up a bit they showed that exact
tension animation he's creeping around
corners wait a minute okay so this is
this is not ten shoe but they're
incorporating things from it and in
seeing all this video now they
for me they've incorporated everything
that was great about ninja gaiden can't
you and the Soul series all one and and
in and even going back to other stealth
series like like I explained or so where
it's your the ability to engage the way
you want is there see in a Souls game
for the most part you're you have to
engage upfront that's it you're you're
face to face right and I have no doubt
in this game that you're the engagements
at least with bosses are gonna be in
that realm while you're it's gonna be
face to face I don't know they're just
gonna allow you to sneak around bosses
and kill them but when engaging with the
world at large it feels like your choice
to engage with your enemies is there you
can be pure stealth yes and then
oftentimes pure self will still open you
up to being attacked by groups of by
groups of enemies and then at that point
you know the real Channel five takes
place where you're you're carrying and
you're going back and forth dodging back
in and out of its I saw things in these
videos it really just blew me away I
know I can't express how excited I am
for suck hero and it's crazy because for
me I enjoy souls games right I don't I'm
not super into like I don't people
really really love them um this might
take me to the next level it really it
really really really is it seems like a
special game to me because it's it
elevates the souls formula and at the
same time I think it makes it more
accessible to people who haven't been
really into the souls games because
because of this ability to tackle things
differently it feels like it could
appeal to more people
mmm you're trending breaking the ninjas
right now you're trying oh yeah I would
jump in real quick cuz you got me height
and I can only Otis to you oh we got to
pay the bills shadow job to be with the
final a super chat speaking with passion
all the jokes to the side ILP one of the
only podcasts that give you real game
with talk salute law or that's my dude
Johnny be with the best jokes in our be
Jack Perry is all Kelly jokes they was
all fine play yeah cuz I would again
Jonathan B if you want these real
raunchy jokes to be shown you found your
conduit I blame you man what they got I
wasn't really checking for signal like
that and then you would tell you mean
you talk actually last night and we only
drive up and shout out to ten dog
Metatron in the crew you know saying
shout the lemon you know saying we had a
good time last night and all yeah it was
like see what Saul talked about with the
latest new stuff right cuz it mama I'm
like okay this is just souls with alone
you know you know background switch so
do you mean so then I'm checking it and
I'm like yo she oh shout the Eurogamer
they got a good one out right now and it
was running all things on another probe
mm-hmm and bro it looked not only did it
look good the thing that surprised me
was like you say it had to stealth then
the traversal with the grappling hook oh
my god was made it so he's moving around
the map you can still view all that
stuff so I'm like okay I had no idea
stealth mechanics were actually in a
souls game it is move super fast move
super fluid the swordplay you gotta be
right you know or timing with your
strikes and stuff like that
your party I think going through it
solve you got me on this because I'm
alone I'll be Freud known them Souls
games it just is not that the games are
wack to me it's just that like I've
never been a fan of like the dark sand
inning and I didn't never like
characters you throw in that feudal
Japan ninjas grappling hook stop now I'm
in no spare so I think I'm with you man
and this more Souls in those other games
and I think the storytelling gonna be
more linear and traditional in those
other games if you look at a Souls game
and you get a blood-borne game like from
software are masters of environmental
storytelling and their worlds are
integral to the story just as much as
anything else right and it these in
their world sort of tend to double back
on each other right and in very
interesting ways and I don't doubt
that's gonna be a case with psyche role
but the fact that the story is so
pronounced and it's not I don't know
that there will be a lot of Secrets
necessarily uncovered I think it's gonna
be a straightforward story
like a revenge tale obviously the
something's gonna come up obviously but
um I think that's gonna help it be
accessible to more people as well yeah
man yeah oh oh well as they say
I guess me about the Sakura is that it
is a stealth aspect of it because the
thing the part that I hate about stealth
games at least ones that provide options
to you is they almost always favor the
loud approach right they almost always
are geared towards that and the stealth
stuff is kind of like a diss announcer
yeah yeah like Assassin's Creed move of
that direction
yeah I know fine Oh for back at agree
with me on that like they move that
direction where at first it was like
okay you can it's geared more towards
stealth but you could you could largely
just do it do what you got to do but
with Sakura because I was one of the
game where it was more like stealth is
the preferred way to do it you can fight
them but it's a pain in the ass and
they're rewarding more for doing
stealthily yeah that'd be interesting
that's got my foot in the door yeah
absolutely yeah what about our undead it
Oh Mike that you guys got any uh
Inklings on second row did anything
change you guys are still getting it off
I'm definitely getting it man I got a
free run I typically don't like stealth
games but I mean I'm not really that big
of a Souls player the only Souls game
that I really got into and enjoyed was
blood-borne but you know just everything
about this game the traversal will the
combat the setting the art style is
something about it just kind of hooked
me and it's like I won't really want to
play it
absolutely unban I don't play from
software games I don't typically like
from software games but I got the Sakura
collector's edition on engines ninjas
and bacon like no seriously Sakura is
what I wanted from software review cuz
honestly I think there's very very
talented studio and they do amazing
things with the Dark Souls series I
think blood-borne was a really good
breakout title of kind of changing their
pace Dark Souls 3 was them perfecting
that formula I think Sakura's got
to an even wider audience because
they're showing we can do this but we
can also do this much more as well and
they are absolutely gonna prove it's
gonna be one of the best games that
releases this year I absolutely believe
that and they're bringing back something
from Demon Souls which people may not
remember is the more times you die
it changes the NPCs around Julie so it
changes how the NPCs interacted some
NPCs they even said in some of the
previous that if you die too many times
certain NPCs and side quests will not be
available to you those NPCs will die
Maya that's fire so you actually have to
it comes to a point if you want to do a
100% run through this game you gotta
count your deaths and make sure that
you're not dying stupidly doing things
rambunctious Lee so this is a very good
be one of those games where you got pace
yourself take your time and that's what
from software games are all about that's
what's up didn't realize that King all
right this is Mitch's my joy is gonna be
twofold all right um
when Phil was on stage and that game was
shown I was like oh my god the new
tenchu I thought was new attention
losing my mind
and um then I said from software and
automatically assign boy because I'm the
one that played blood-borne and couldn't
get past the werewolf when we first
started and now I'm the one to play Dark
Souls and I was trying to figure out why
is this dead guy here and he was telling
me something but I died just like the
dude right there I'm that guy I'm that
guy that tries to play these dog soul
games that send soul of redemption join
I'm trying I'm trying i my skill is not
of that caliber for this I need to just
run in and shoot stuff up and bang stuff
out pause all right so now this is what
we used to do back in our you know
tenchu days we used to give the
controller to kognito and sovereign
right and we all sit in the dog eat and
pop
watching them play there they will go
and sinister and they would sneak around
corners and killing people
so that's why I mind my skill of that
game never um group so at one point I
was my was super elated right then when
I saw set some software I stood there
goes my game in the bushes
alright so I'm gonna say this right I
hope it makes it the game pass I really
hope it does because there's another
game like neo that neo game yeah
PlayStation right now
now this don't let me know if I'm right
or wrong here but I know souls games
making it onto the Xbox platform was a
huge thing advice and the fact that this
game has come in date and day to our
Xbox and a PlayStation platform I don't
know if is launched on PC the same day
and that's a huge thing
um for those people that love this type
of break your controller I don't know
what I'm gonna do with my life next type
of game um for me the fact that from
software is on the develop I can't buy
this game but just their name their
presence of difficulty alone I would
watch a stream or play it off I would
admire it from a distance but if
forgetting the game past I - whoa cry
and talk controller but I'm not buying
this game to be frustrated as also we
got kissable we definitely doing that a
second whole challenge just like he did
right on so he's got that going on and
we got one more what's that that is gone
man yeah man so okay so days gone was a
game that when it was initially shown in
2016 a lot of people sort of just
laughed it out of the building it wasn't
necessarily of good showing and it
looked like it was a cookie cutter a
cookie cutter zombie game that was
trying to to capitalize on the zombie
craze and it was sort of uh
what many people felt was a weird game
to sort of promote on the Sony side with
the humungous shadow of last of us to
sort of looming it didn't make sense to
sort of be promoting this type of gaben
to be putting this game this type of
game out um so now three years later we
finally were the games going gold it's
releasing in April and we finally been
able to get I guess the embargo lifted
on a few hours of initial gameplay and I
have to say for the most part the
previews that I've seen everyone who
would had an initial trepidation about
this game is saying this game is
probably gonna be good maybe great and
it speaks it speaks to a couple of
things right it speaks to things that
we've always given Sony credit for which
is sticking with with properties and
with games that people maybe they're the
initial releases aren't the greatest and
then they allow them to flourish and
become great and the fact that they
didn't sort of tell Ben to go back to
the drawing board and maybe this is not
a route that we want to take and they
allowed them to continue to make this
game and polish it to the point that
it's now something that some people are
super excited for at least I think it's
it's it's great and I think it's
interesting and and asked for me not one
of those that was really on you know I I
was down on it outside this doesn't feel
like anything super interesting um it
just doesn't feel like it feels like a
really real cookie cutter take on the
Sony formula drive and then seeing some
of this preview stuff I'm like wow maybe
they made the combat deeper they've
allowed you to now choose how you engage
things much in the same way like like
Sakura yet you can do things stealthily
you can do things sort of blowing
everything up um and then the crafting
mechanic and the sort of uh the economy
and sort of upgrading of your weapons
and stuff like that seems like it's
refined in a way that's very cool that
again it wasn't something that that they
net necessarily were able to explain
properly when they first talked about
the game in addition to that the whole
thing about the freaker's though you
know the zombies that are in the game
yeah expanded I know one thing that
people thought was cool when they
initially talked about the game was how
you could sort of funnel them into these
choke points and try to kill them there
was there was some sort of strategy
involved and I think that whole thing
yeah so I I think that whole thing
they've sort of expanded on and I
honestly like pretty much every single
preview that I've seen has turned on the
game mm-hmm turn in a positive way yeah
yeah let's get in good man wait yeah
baby's gone man I want to say first of
all you're welcome
you guys live on the show mr. undead oh
I didn't know he was a lead just because
every generic white guy with a beard
like come on and he still has the best
porno name in the business is it does it
interest you a little bit more you
weren't really messing with it well yeah
Woody's gone it's a zombie game I don't
care in the bushes oh there you go all
that is ostensibly a zombie game I'm
talking about the zombies are the only
enemy type in this game we call them
wherever you want their zombies groups
and stuff you gotta fight against that
of interest like really truth will get
man I just finished the Resident Evil 2
I gotta go back to state of decay to
still bushes oh just because Sambi you
just you just gotta get away from the
zombies or you just think I'm just you
know I'll say I did see the new game
play for it's just that I don't know I
just I just got a want to cool it on the
zombies for a little bit yeah okay it
was
I'll be back in 2012 I mean this leader
on undead while we admit I'm in days
gone day one there's car days gone is a
zombie game so I'm there day one unlike
Mike and Ivan I 100 percent zombie games
I play them I buy them like one of my
favorite games of this generation stay
decay - okay like the amount of fun I
had with friends and the amount of time
I put into that game the fact that I
still boot that game up at least once a
week to dive in and have some more fun I
love zombie games
I love Sony Bend they have a pedigree
with the Syphon Filter series they did
an amazing Uncharted Vita title mmm they
are their pedigree speaks volumes for
who they are the fact they've been
working on this game for like six seven
years I'm very excited to see what
they're gonna do with it
they have settled some in some worries I
had there were some things about the
game that kind of made me go really
that's a weird design choice because it
was like a really super serious setting
they were trying to sell and then they
had him on the motorcycle and I'm like
so if they're attracted to noise and I'm
driving around on a motorcycle like I've
got questions I've got questions but
they seem to have ironed out the
character they seemed to have ironed a
what this game is which is very
important I think what they really need
to do before they launch this game
though is they really need to sell
people that this isn't the Last of Us
because they've done a really poor job
prior to the most recent previews at
showing what this game does differently
than the Last of Us because the thing is
is with the Last of Us you had to focus
okay I've got three clickers two bullets
and one brick how am I gonna get through
this right whereas with this game you're
still gonna need to do resource
management everything else but you're
gonna run into hordes where you're
facing like thousands of these things
right and you need to show that off and
especially need to show off this horde
tech that they're using because we have
World War Z dropping the week before
which is also selling horde
quote-unquote horde tech yes so they
need to diversify and show what this
game
but I'm really excited about I'm glad to
see that they've taken this year it's
compared to what we saw last year in
that game or even earlier yeah it was
last year with the game and for more
preview whereas kind of looking really
rough the bullet played it the gun
played in looking they've really taken
that time they've polished it up I'm
really excited for it I think it'll be a
good game I don't think people need to
put in like the Spider Man god ward not
every game is gonna hit that level but I
think this is gonna be a really solid
good game yeah young good lord King man
Dave's going whatever no no now this
right here I give to every last one I
use Sony fake fans oh alright I want to
tell you so many fans you sonic fraud
fans every every last one of y'all I
don't want y'all to keep that same
energy when the game comes out I don't
want y'all to talk about I was riding
day one second I saw that game I said I
am in if I don't I don't care what I
like under said he saw something
anything I solved that game it was Oh
top quality to me and I see now you see
the from software you saw this dad was
in my genrih here we go here we go this
my John right now popping them guns so
I'm popping them guns I'm gonna from
zombies and blowing them up I told my
son the other day I said I can't wait to
get that game in the house like it says
zombies on fire that's exactly what I
told him he said are we going to do it
together daddy all right so I'm molding
him into a little King so the fact that
I'm able to horde him up into one area
and get a mass killing opens a kill
count all right the game you listen
listen it's phenomenal yeah um so Lee
does single play experiences better than
anybody this generation so I don't know
who the hell was questioning what was
going on over there Sony but I know it
wasn't that game you're supposed to be
questioning now maybe y'all want the
last of us first see this is what you're
suffering from of Captain Marvel
avengers endgame itís right you're
looking forward to the endgame but
you're not trying
to get this game first right so you're
not gonna respect this game now you're
gonna have some people come out and say
oh this game isn't really what I wanted
okay so you really want the last of us
save your bucks for the last of us and
don't worry about this don't put your
two cents into this if you're not even
go on it you go in half on it
save your wallet and go to the last of
us but this guy is gonna get the highest
level edition I can get for this game
because it looks amazing and I'm playing
on a pro I don't play on a simple a slim
basic lab strain if you have a pro I
don't want it nothing you talking about
Louis that's what's going on ever see
Rev in a minute we gotta get them all
yes yeah I'm which listen its way cuz
late I was calling it like sons anarchy
zombies like you I like it feel like I
mean even from the beginning you know I
just like that high tech I like how like
it was massive zombies and you could use
you know stuff against them you know
with the initial vision and then they
had like the arm the other rifle group
so it was like yeah the zombies you had
the humans human gangs and stuff like
that I like that they really went back
in the drawing board they kind of like
improve the narrative aspect so that
part to me really showed me that they
take it a little bit more serious and
shout out the band man like they listen
in to the complaints you know me a lot
of people didn't like the initial stuff
even though I liked it and they gave it
time to cook so based on what I'm seeing
you know I'm with on dead man like I
like zombie games as long as it's done
right the story the narrative is cool
and they do the again that dynamic
between the human gangs and the zombie
hordes they got you know and it gets you
a little Daryl Dixon on yokai in all
that you can don't you really want to be
able to bring a [ __ ] rival and set it
up and just sit in the back and watch
them eat them this is what I wanna do
it's funny you said that because I
remember one of the early previews of
the game they were using the Horde as a
mechanic in their enemies like I like
did that aspect of it so I'm win it man
I'm gonna give it a shot man again I
think people got to keep their
expectations in check not everything
gonna be gotta warn and everything gonna
be Last of Us and I think what
what it is I think for the Sony base
because last of us is there and it is
what it is and as soon as you see
zombies you automatically kind of pit
lane and they're not trying to do this
if you like you said King if you coming
to me and looking for Last of Us this is
not that I'm saying but let's give it a
shot on its own merit and I think it
might be a solid you know seven eight
see what it do man that's so like so
well maybe I got out of here you already
know about the Xbox said you know it's
out here the old digital and we talked
about it but I solve you want to finish
up your topic and then we just get you
yeah I'm just I'm just a super excited
for these games man we had we've had
some start to the year in kind of nuts
and when it comes to second row like I'm
double dipping like we're gonna be we're
gonna be a pax when that games out and
I'm not taking my class with me so yeah
I'll be getting it on PCs ah I meant to
ask you a question earlier do you think
that grow existing is a sign that
blood-borne two is dead I don't think so
I think blood-borne two is is it's still
gonna be a Sony property so I think you
know they're just taking their sweet
time with it and and they wanted to do
something different with the formula I'm
glad because that means we're getting it
on Xbox and blood-borne two wasn't I
don't think that's happening so I don't
think it's dead not at all mmm yeah that
day's going your and I already know I
just want to throw in the we got the
official name for the digital system
there the clownin itself they call it
the sand that acronym please who's
naming things over Xbox real quick
because we already the Lords already
kind of talked about this as far as the
all digital system you know at least my
perspective is more experimental phase
they wanted you know trying to test the
market and then see what happens as far
as our maybe potentially Lockhart or if
it gets a good reception
multi-verse boys what do you guys think
man as far as the console I mean you
could call me Nostradamus cuz I wrote an
article like a year ago about this and I
call they were gonna do this eventually
no I mean it's inevitable and I mean if
there's a way that they come out with an
all-digital cons
and whatever cost savings they have from
that sell it at a cheaper price help
them more move more units you know I
think it's a no-brainer for them you
know if people people are out there
crapping on it on social media
nobody's saying you have to buy it it's
just an option correctness they saying
is not the same is the Xbox cha Dae sa
de maybe that's they said we got it oh
but we gotta throw that eel with respect
on it smooth operator
[Laughter]
you want to go oh no its options I got
an ex I really don't care about having
another Xbox I'm past that point
options are good people can buy whatever
they want to buy a digital only console
makes sense I would have loved to have
seen them do something with the ex do a
disco sex make it cheaper that would
have been because we've seen it in MPD's
MP and P DS dad is stating the pros and
X's are the months they're moving really
well so if they made a diskless X or a
pro why I'd understand that a bit more I
think it's just options and they're
testing the waters on can we sell people
a digital only console will people buy
that mm-hmm yeah but let you close it
out I think it really just because it's
flying paper like you can buy like when
se you - for what 300 bucks
some like that new all right if it's not
gonna be significantly cheaper it's not
gonna really matter right so you what
was that no I'm sorry you think it's got
to be significantly so like give me a
price point that you think it could work
like if this thing is under 200 bucks a
day once I mean I mean mmm yes right now
y'all was the eyes right now like 250
that's still too much
two-fifty but you get it for one 7995
you know on a black day you bust that
down to like a 150 and the dog get him
and get amount type of thing I honestly
would once the next generation starts up
I will get my children that this system
as far as just you know having a stream
box type of digital thing so you know it
is viable for my children he's not
viable for me I need that 4k beautiful
mr. oh you already know oh you know so
that's what you got that's what you got
in the price for Hank alright yeah it's
gotta be can't be cheaper to be worth
our time there we go yeah I heard it
from the fans get that shot a price down
we in there so let's wrap this out of
here man new ILP poll this week with the
recent ps4 firmware announcement
allowing remote play functionality to
iOS phones and tablets do you think this
will eventually lead to Sony adopting a
more aggressive streaming approach with
PS now the choices are a no remote plane
has existed for years PlayStation now
will remain the same B yes similar to X
Cloud PlayStation now will evolve to any
device or C I don't care I'm not
interested unless I get that PS now on
my toaster those please like the I hate
people when it goes up
lords of the multi-verse and pleasure
that have you in the world we can find
people find you what do you have going
on stop alone anchorman right so you
could find me personally an anchorman me
too and pretty much every single
platform Xbox Playstation if you want
mice which social security number you
don't you can find me on Instagram
Twitter or whatever income in youtube if
you want a multi pursue and watch us and
like I stuck and go find us on YouTube
and multiverse show where you can find
us we're also at multiverse show and I
know space for that one we are going
live tomorrow at 8 p.m. so as we
normally do Mondays mmm
what you're gonna talk about that
Captain Marvel maybe I might go see that
later today I know that um James has
seen it I know the Sam get seen it also
you got a yes I gotta see if I can make
it out today you'll see it or not no
absolute pleasure to have the multi Bros
in the building Lord Mike PV truth with
his day view the dawn of the lead to the
gimmick damn Queen you know Mom man
what's going on man where could I find
people find your brother all right guys
you can find me right in opinion pieces
for the inner circle at tick games
network.com um pretty much every gaming
platform at Mike Peeta truth kinda like
what I haven't said if you want my
switch international phone numbers and
on Twitter and the truth of Mike pro2
truth might be debuted on Dave my man
the lord of perspective and the infinite
infinite reoccurring multiverse guest
we're gonna pop you will find you go
people can find me on Twitter add on
dead 3 xvi you can add me on PlayStation
Xbox steam halt on dead 3 XVI I do not
have a switch social security number you
can find anything I write opinions
pieces news everything else that's it
games Network calm and the gaming
perspective podcast every Saturday night
at 8 p.m. Eastern Standard Time
no doubt you already know Lord addict is
in the bushes at work so we won't shout
him out wait now Lord solve what's going
on man look at a fabulous fine Japan you
can find me on Twitter at Lord South ILP
and PSN xbox live at BX sovereign big
shoutouts you guys multiverse man
pleasure to have you guys finally at
least at least some of you are good
alright gonna have the battery at least
the whole panel you're still seven hours
show every node Elsa Lord of the iron
bank Lord King out here lab Oh shaming
yo check this out right so y'all see
that giant statue over there right yeah
seen a Voltron right this is a huge
statue I will have my son stand next to
it but he's upstairs playing um this
week on king of the statues every
Wednesday 7:00 a.m. standard Eastern
Time used to stand the time you're going
to see this week I'm gonna debut a new
series in the king of the statues format
is going to be our vs. series is gonna
be a statue versus another statue might
be our line versus another line but this
week um debuted for catches oh we have
for begin for I mean I got a lot of I
gotta shake it up people all right but
uh four statues for epic statues for
statue that's going to yank it your
childhood I had somebody DM me and told
me that Voltron made him cry and they
heard the music
and he was like oh yeah yeah he's like
where where can i get it how can I get
us a brother it is sold out and it was
1,400 if you can get it after market you
could probably get it for two grand on
eBay if somebody is selling it to you um
but also combat talk with the King this
week it comes out when I wanna alright
when I want to watch a fight when I was
a fight worth my time this weekend yeah
Shawn Porter versus you guys I thought
you guys was gonna beat him
I watched the fight who does did beat
him but did he get the victory no he
didn't get the victory because you guys
has not managed by our Heyman and Shawn
Porter is and they need Shawn Porter to
fight somebody else to lose to somebody
with a name alright I would have told
you that anyway if you guys did not come
out then who guys was not gonna win the
belt it wasn't because he fight this
weekend
Cognito and sovereign can attest to that
in the bushes he got smoked out here the
Senate toast did his did shadows I got
him mhm
it was definitely go time it was
definitely worthwhile but um catch us at
Lords of game and dotnet justice at the
last word stead of right right now been
practicing so davechowie Bob
you already know what it means man look
I'm gonna go shout again to the Lord of
the multiverse finally got a chance to
get this thing done hit that like
subscribe all that notification gang all
that you already know the odd timestamps
and the audio will be up by my man Lord
carboxyl free later tonight tomorrow
morning the latest and the links will be
on that make sure you please check out
Lords of gaming that net all your latest
gaming news a lot of walk through a lot
of stuff going out and yeah mess I'm
gonna hottest riders up and coming in
the game trying to get their pieces to
you so please support them when they can
shout to the stream team Lord Senado
l-boogie chat I Sawyer and old-school
style MJ's a boss and Lord Dunlap oh
we're gonna be still streaming actually
Lord addict but now he's got a PC so he
will be a little bit more active now and
I'll check out for that dream daddy
challenge that he asked as good a video
there's gonna be absolutely hilarious
the beard will be in the game king of
statues number three like a king said
you got a tour for number four is coming
but number three is out there I want to
hear that proper light on you know I'm
saying it was really a spectacular if
you want a PC a childhood please check
it out he's got one video of the
unboxing another video of a breakdown of
the piece it's fantastically done music
is great and he's got the best intro
beat in the business so please support
my brother Lord King out there and your
II know he bought this number 52 last
word is up you're getting into that
destiny division and anthem looter
shooter talk you already know the vision
is coming so we had to talk about that
as well everybody enjoy your Sunday if
anybody got anything else all right wait
wait
[Laughter]